ul du club international de discussion
valdaï
c'est avec une émotion particulière que
jean vite sur celle notre en-but et
notre hôte de marque le président de la
russie vladimir poutine
ce warning et ils sont ravis de revoir
en présentiel parce que l'année dernière
à cause des circonstances bien connu on
a connu qu'émet un format virtuel et
finalement où la vie commence à battre
son plein cette année notre cession
s'est déroulée de
façon très riche il ya eu beaucoup de
tension peut-être
beaucoup de personnes
voudrais aborder des sujets précis
ce qui est intéressant c'était inattendu
mais finalement la politique mondiale
aujourd'hui est un sujet très important
il faut l'aborder ne s'est pas
l'essentiel parce que bien sûr elle
change mais la pandémie ne l'a pas
renversé et elle le fait la situation où
vivent les gens comment où les gens
commencent à construire une relation
dans ce nouveau contexte les relations
entre les états ça c'est essentiel et
nous avons eu ce sujet à travers sa
transversale je pense que nous allons en
parler pour l'instant j'ai le plaisir de
vous inviter à présenter vos propos
cher participants à la session plénière
tout d'abord je tiens à vous remercier
d'être venu en russie pour participer
à la rencontre du club de valdaï et au
cours de ces rencontres
comme toujours son soulevé un certain
nombre de questions importantes
d'actualité ce sont des questions qui
sans exagération sont d'actualité pour
tout le monde dans pour tous les pays
est un des thèmes principaux de ce forum
qui
suppose donc les grandes secousses
actuelle c'est-à-dire l'homme l'état et
les valeurs et si je si vous permettez
je vais justement abordé l'ordre du jour
actuelle et cette phrase de vivre en
période de troubles c'est une phrase
peut être éculé mais cette époque de
bouleversements l'a commencé assez
longtemps et donc cet état nous devient
habituel est-ce qu'il faut vraiment
prêter une grande attention là dessus eh
bien je suis d'accord avec ceux qui ont
choisi cette formulation de la
thématique de cette rencontre au cours
des
dernières décennies nous avons pu nous
souvenir des grandes paroles de sagesse
de la sagesse chinoise
et qu'on peut évoquer aujourd'hui
c'est à dire que dieu nous préserve de
vivre pendant une période de troubles
est-ce que nous le voulions ou pas
mais en tout cas ces bouleversements
sont de plus en plus essentiel de plus
en plus profond
et il ya une autre phrase de la sagesse
chinoise qui vous et c'est à dire que
qui est que la sagesse il ya peut-être
deux représentants chinois ici il me
corrige bon si c'est faux mais
la sagesse est exprimée en deux
idéogrammes le danger et la décision le
choix qui est fait voilà
donc nous devons combiner
expérience c est d'angers pour savoir
résister pour savoir riposter
les dangers sont multiples ils sont
variés mais il est important aussi
nécessaire de se rappeler du deuxième
élément qui signifie la crise c'est la
possibilité c'est à dire c'est une
possibilité dont nous devons que nous
devons utiliser et c'est ici une crise
civilisationnelle c'est une crise qui
porte sur l'ensemble des approches qui
concerne l'humanité et auquel il faut
réfléchir
dans quel sens dans quelle direction
devant nos avancées quels sont les
correctifs à apporter
pour identifier les valeurs qu'il
convient de défendre donc l'humanité
connaît une nouvelle période cela
commençait déjà à dia trois quatre
décennies
on a une opposition politique et
idéologique qui existait on en a
beaucoup parlé lors des différentes
plateformes de
discussion et le mini affaires
étrangères on a parlé aussi mais on peut
peut-être à l'époque on recherchait un
nouvel équilibre pour plus de stabilité
sociale économique culturelle et aussi
sur le plan militaire et donc et un
nouvel appui pour l' équilibre
international il faut reconnaître que
aujourd'hui nous n'avons pas encore
réussi à trouver cet équilibre est ce
qui a après la fin de la guerre froide
se sont sentis vainqueurs ont vite senti
malgré la sensation qu'ils avaient de se
trouver dans l'olympe que le la terre se
dérober sous leurs pieds et aujourd'hui
n'est en mesure de mettre certains de du
choix qui a été fait aujourd'hui cette
espèce changeant ce passage à
l'aléatoire
aujourd'hui c'est ce que nous avons
devant nous et les acteurs que nous
sommes
nous devons
nous avons l'humanité a connu beaucoup
de bouleversements
et ce n'est pas simplement un mouvement
dans l' équilibre des forces bien que il
est cela se produise aussi mais
aujourd'hui sommes confrontés à des
changements systémiques sur tous les
plans dans toutes les directions qu'il
s'agisse de l'état de notre planète que
si aussi paradoxal que cela puisse être
sur le sens de l'existence humaine ici
alors regardons autour de nous et encore
une fois je me permette de vous faire
part des pensées qui me viennent à
l'esprit
on a une déformation une dégradation du
milieu de l'environnement dans lequel
nous vivons et on ne peut pas y échapper
on peut
poursuivre les discussions scientifiques
sur les mécanismes d'évolution mais en
tout cas tout le monde est bien
comprendre que ces processus ne font que
se renforcer
les séismes interviennent sur mer sur
terre
ils deviennent presque une norme on
commence à devoir sont aussi habitués
quand on a vu l'été dernier les
inondations gigantesques en europe les
incendies de forêt en sibérie mais pas
seulement aux cyber et puisque en
turquie aussi on a vu ce qui s'est passé
aux états unis
et d'une manière générale sur le compte
en main continent américain et on voit
que tous les domaines de compétition
scientifique
vous font penser que les confrontations
politiques n'ont plus aucun sens on voit
tout simplement qu'il ya des soit fait
et on peut pas satisfaire cette soif
aujourd'hui on a cet obstacle de la
pandémie on voit que notre vie est
vulnérable lorsqu'il faut aujourd'hui
ses assurés l'année il ya la nécessité
d'assurer la stabilité et la vie de
l'humanité et la capacité à survivre au
cataclysme qui interviennent dans notre
vie comment notre mode d'habitat est
organisée comment les villes sont
organisées comment organiser le
développement économique des pays et
tout cela et ça c'est ça fait partie des
impératifs prioritaires
et essayez donc de dire que ce n'est pas
le cas or c'est par ça
et donc la question qui se pose c'est
pourquoi on n'est pas toujours capable
d'être prêt et de répondre à ces défis
on voit aujourd'hui ces perturbations
qui interviennent aujourd'hui est sur
tous les plans
dans le monde et tout le monde constate
bien que le modèle du capitalisme
qui constitue aujourd'hui la base de la
majorité des pays a cessé de se
détériorer justifiées y ait plus de
moyens de sortir de ses contradictions
on voit partout même dans les pays les
régions les plus riches du monde
il ya le problème de répartition des
biens qui mène aujourd'hui a de plus en
plus d'inégalités au sein de la société
et sur le plan international on voit des
oppositions
c'est un défi important que j'avais
exprimé déjà lors du forum de
davos
et tous ces problèmes sont essentielles
et ils sont des causes de rupture on
voit certain nombre de régions qui
connaissent aujourd'hui des problèmes
alimentaires mais il ya toutes les
raisons de croire aujourd'hui que cette
crise alimentaire cette crise va
s'approfondir
qu'il s'agisse de du manque d'eau du
manque d'énergie tout cela ce sont des
produits dont on peut parler du du nid
du taux de pauvreté
tout cela ce sont des problèmes qui se
posent aujourd'hui et pour certains pays
l'objectif les objectifs fixés
deviennent de moins en moins accessible
et un cela pousse une partie de la
population dans l'extrémisme dans
certains pays où voit
augmenter
le sentiment de désarroi face aux
attentes non satisfaites pas seulement
pour soi mais aussi pour la génération
qui nous suit pour les enfants et cela
mène à des recherches à la recherche
d'une solution pour avoir une meilleure
part à limiter l'immigration
en voit un renforcement du
mécontentement social
nous à vis de l'état par exemple j'ai
rien mais expliquez vous le voyez vous
même et vous vous prenez ça peut-être
même mieux que moi il ya d'autres
problèmes sociaux qui sont influencés
par les défis qui se posent aujourd'hui
est
aujourd'hui la priorité n'est peut-être
plus la lutte d'influencé mais plutôt
on a des réactions qui sont
hypertrophiées ils sont exagérées et
dans beaucoup de pays la réaction de la
jeunesse a montré que je le suis
j'espère que d'autres on nous parlait
avant moi
mais l'infection n'a été qu'un
moteur un motif de troubles sociaux qui
ont été bien plus approfondie la
pandémie de cornas virus qui est
théoriquement aurait dû
pousser les gens à plus de cohésion
provoquant contraire plus de disparités
et de rupture entre les gens il ya
beaucoup de causes à cela mais une des
causes c'est que on a cherché à trouver
des solutions dans les modes habituels
de fonctionnement de la société or on
voit que il ne fonctionne pas ou qu'ils
ont un effet contraire qu'il ne fait
qu'aggraver la situation
et je le répète encore le défi qui est
lancé ici
notamment de certains de vouloir
promouvoir leurs intérêts de ce n'est
pas toujours
nous parlons de la nécessité de lutter
ensemble contre le coronavirus les déjà
sur le plan humanitaire je parle même
pas de la russie
laissons de côté les sanctions mais les
sanctions sont maintenues contre les
pays qui justement sont le plus en
manque de besoin pour le thé concept
pandémie donc et on ne voit pas
disparaître ces obstacles au contraire
ils ne font que se maintenir notamment
dans la pensée occidentale
alors que en traités y aurait rien à
faire et on voit que du bavardage
et c'est ça qu'on voit ensuite la
révolution technologique
avec les succèdent en matière
d'intelligence artificielle
de
d'ingénierie médicale
climatique etc on voit qu'un certain
nombre de questions sociales
philosophique
intellectuels se pose est que va-t-il se
passer quand la technologie dépassera
les capacités humaines quand l'homme
cessera d'être un être humain et ne sera
qu'une est un être humain
quelconque et là les potentialités
scientifiques seront sans limites et
cela signifie que pour nous pour chacun
d'entre nous pour
nos successeurs pour nos enfants
directement et tout cela va modifier
leur mode de vie et cela ne s'arrêtera
pas et ces changement seront des
changements objectivement très profond
indépendamment de de la structure
politique du pays ou de l'idéologie
dominante
évidemment en paroles tous les pays sont
sur un plan d'égalité peuvent coopérer
pour travailler à résoudre les problèmes
mais malheureusement ce ne sont que des
paroles dans la réalité on voit
exactement le contraire et la pandémie
je le répète n'a fait que renforcer les
tendances que nous observons depuis
longtemps qu à les renforcer
et
défendre ses intérêts ses propres
intérêts aux dépens des autres ça
devient finalement le la règle
principale
et un goût un certain nombre d'intérêts
communs qui ont été mis de côté pour aux
dépens des intérêts personnels
certains états avec leurs élites
[Musique]
ont une vision du monde qui est perturbé
au lieu d'un an c'est qu'en réalité on
n'a pas tout blancs d'un côté tout noir
de l'autre côté il faut assurer la
sécurité le bien-être de la population
et donc les sujets de
les thématiques
transfrontières internationale
doivent être un mode de réflexion et les
modes de fonctionnement admis à
l'international ne correspond pas
toujours à la dynamique des changements
qui interviennent dans le monde et cette
pandémie a montré que certaines
institutions ont effectivement un
potentiel et d'autres ont cessé d'en
avoir or là il faut ici travailler à une
re une ré nouvelle répartition des
forces
pour satisfaire ceux qui sont
aujourd'hui
délaissée
à la fin du xxème siècle
nous voyons maintenant un système plus
multiple c'est processus d'enterrement
de transformation ne sont pas mécanique
je dirais uniques en leur genre
l'histoire politique ne connaît pas
encore un des exemples où l'ordre
mondial ne serait pas instaurer sans une
grande gare comme c'était le cas après
la deuxième guerre mondiale
cela dit nous avons la possibilité de
voir ce précédent unique à le faire
après la fin de la guerre froide
la domination de l'occident ce n'était
pas réussi alors nous devons tirer les
leçons
force est de constater que
paradoxalement
depuis des deux décennies
un pays le plus puissant
mener des campagnes militaires dans deux
états qui n'étaient pas comparables avec
cette puissance mais à la fin cette
puissance a dû abandonner ses campagnes
militaires
sans aucun résultat qui a été posée il
ya une quinzaine d'années cette
puissance abandonner ces pays
en portant un grand préjudice à ce pays
et à d'autres la situation s'est empirée
radicalement
mais auparavant
la victoire d'un pays signifier la
défaite de notre par exemple la défaite
des états unis au vietnam
n'a pas été suivi par la transformation
du vietnam à un trou noir au contraire
ce pays se développe maintenant grâce au
soutien de son allié mais aujourd'hui il
en est autrement quoi qu'il en dise la
guerre est transformé et le vainqueur
conditionnelle ne veut pas
reconstruire ce pays et en pire des
choses
sa collègue
qu'elles sont à notre point de vue les
grandes repères de la transformation
mondiale très en bref je vais formuler
quelques thèses
d'abord à la pandémie de coronavirus a
montré que
seul l'état pourrait être le facteur de
la transformation mondiale
toutes les plateformes numériques sont
les puissantes je le constate nous les
avons vus dans le politique intérieure
des états unis mais de toute façon
il ne faut pas usurpée les fonctions
politiques
par ces plateformes ce sont des
tentatives éphémère dans les états unis
les patrons de ces plateformes
numériques ont eu raison de leur place
ailleurs il ya des amendes
il ya toutes sortes de mesures pour des
monopolisé cette activité vous le savez
depuis la première décennie en anglais
des concepts qui
disait que l'état c'est une chose
obsolète et dans le contexte de la
modélisation les frontières nationales
devient une sorte d'anachronisme
vous savez je l'aï répété à maintes
reprises
c'était les paroles de ceux qui
voudraient forcer les frontières
d'autres pays
mais dès que l'on s'avère que quelqu'un
obtient des résultats meilleurs en
revient à la fermeture de ses propres
frontières par exemple les frontières
douanières et j'en passe on commence à
construire des murs on le voit toujours
tout le monde le voit et tout le monde
le comprend très bien
aujourd'hui personne ne le contexte
conteste c'est évident mais
le développement à partir de la
nécessité de l'ouverture de la frontière
a
connu un sens inverse mais l'état
souverain est capable de répondre aux
besoins des gens et l'ordre mondial doit
prendre en compte les intérêts des états
et non pas essayer de prouver que les
frontières ne peuvent pas exister on
peut pas imposer quelque chose à
d'autres par exemple les principes de la
structure politico bien les principes
disons universel il est évident que
quand une crise sérieuse vient il ya une
seule valeur c'est la vie humaine
comment protéger cette vie chacun et un
trouve sa propre solution en partant de
sa culture de ses traditions
et dans ce sens
je voudrais souligner la menace de cette
pandémie qui a emporté partout dans le
monde le 2 4 millions 900 mille
personnes ne se sort des chiffres
dangereux qui dépasse ses les pertes
militaires et durant la première guerre
mondiale
deuxième sujet auquel je porte votre
attention les échelles de ces
transformations nous oblige d'être très
prudent
ne serait ce que par le sentiment de
l'auto défense puisque tous les
changements dans l'environnement c'est
la transformation
qui ne signifie pas que nous devons
réagir de façon radicale hui on peut
démonter tout mais il est très difficile
de construire nous le savons très bien
réussi
il ya une centaine d'années la russie de
façon objective
suite à la première guerre mondiale a
traversé une période très difficile mais
pas plus que d'autres pays
peut-être dans une échelle montre
est la russie pourrait les surmonter de
façon aussi civilisationnel mais il ya
eu des transformations révolutionnaire
et qui ont amené aux débâcles de
l'empiré russe il ya une trentaine
d'années la puissance et qui est l union
soviétique n'a pas
trouvé la voie de transformation
raisonnée et donc toutes sortes de
progressistes réactionnaire on
travaillait pour faire échouer ce pays
oui bien sûr la relation s'est pas une
voie de solution de crise mais plutôt la
vie la voix d'aggraver cette crise
aucune révolution ne valait pas le
préjudice qu'elle portait aux
potentiellement troisième sujet dans
notre monde fragile 1
nous avons besoin d'un soutien éthiques
un soutien des valeurs les valeurs c'est
le produit du développement culturel de
chaque nation c'est un produit unique
le trois mâts des peuples nous enrichit
l'ouverture ouvre l'horizon de notre
pensée élargi notre pensée mais ce
processus doit être organique
bien sûr nous allons abandonner ce qui
est étranger pour nous et il ne faut pas
imposer les valeurs et imposer des
perspectives qui complique une situation
et qui engendre une réaction contraire
au résultat qu'on attend avec surprise
nous voyons les processus qui se
développe dans des pays que ceux ci
considèrent comme les fleurons je
prendrais bien sûr les transformations
socio culturel aux états unis en europe
c'est pas la faire à nous nous ne
cesserons nous ne serons pas dans les
affaires mais la discrimination
d'une majorité pour les intérêts des
minorités aux biens abandon des grandes
valeurs comme la famille la mère la
distinction des genres
ce ne sont pas des repères à vers le
renouveau de la société à notre avis est
encore une fois
je voudrais souligner oui c'est leur
droit à eux il n'y a pas d'ingérence de
notre part mais s'il vous plaît ne vous
ne verrez pas dans notre pays nous avons
une autre vision puisque la majorité de
la société russe
pour être précis à un autre point de vue
nous avons nos propres valeurs
historiques notre culture de notre
peuple multiethnique
les adeptes du progrès social
veulent porter une sorte de nouvelle
mentalité plus correct qu'auparavant
nous vous souhaitons beaucoup de succès
nous leur souhaitons beaucoup de succès
mais je veux dire une chose
les recettes qu'il propose ne sont pas
nouvelles tout ça
peut-être cela va vous surprendre
nous allons connu tout ça en russie
c'était le cas dans le passé en russie
les bolchéviks par exemple après la
révolution de 1917
en se basant sur les dogmes de la
théorie de marx et d'un gel ce disait
aussi qu'ils vont transformer
tout le monde non seulement du point de
vue économique social mais le concept de
de la moralité
ils voulaient perturber et les grandes
valeurs de l'humanité abandonné la
famille c'était le cas dans le passé de
la russie
imposer
le progrès qui était un autre et c'était
soutenu partout dans le monde comme
aujourd'hui
à propos les bolchéviques et est
intolérant par rapport à d'autres
opinions
cela nous rappelle tout ce qui se passe
aujourd'hui quand nous voyons tout ce
qui se passe dans quelques pays nous
reconnaissons les pratiques d'antan en
russie que nous avons abandonné la lutte
pour l'égalité contre la discrimination
est transformé en absurdité quand
on
refuse à apprendre les oeuvres de
shakespeare parce que les idées de
shakespeare sont obsolètes
les oeuvres classiques
sont déclarés obsolètes parce qu'elle
est ne prennent pas
l'égalité des sexes
on discute de la couleur des personnages
des films hollywoodiens
et et
on se rappelle que la propagande du
comité central du parti communiste de
l'union soviétique
était peut-être un petit enfant par
rapport à ça mais de toute façon dans
cette
can seul coach c'est une autre
discrimination c'est le racisme
contraire un
canton souligne à ce sujet raciale
c'est une pomme de discorde entre les
gens et je vous rappelle que
j'ai demandé une situation de martin
luther king qui disaient que je rêve de
l'époque où
mes quatre enfants vivront dans un pays
où on juge pas à part à base de la
couleur de la peau mais à base des
qualités personnelles voilà les valeurs
fondamentales mais quelque chose ne veut
pas aujourd'hui en russie
la majorité des russes n'ont aucune
différence
quelle est la couleur de la peau une
dame où monsieur
une personne devant vous c'est
l'important c'est une sorte de
fantasmagorie la diski et discussions
autour des droits des femmes et des
hommes les bolchéviks
disait un peu quelque chose quand il
parlait de l'égalité des sexes et donc
les notions déjà pourrait être
abandonnée même mais les femmes et les
hommes existent c'est un fait biologique
qui est contestée maintenant par exemple
par un numéro un par un numéro 2
par an qui a accouché et non pas la mer
on abandonne
les notions du lait maternel en disant
que c'est du lait humain
mais je répète ce n'est pas du nouveau
parce que dans les années 20
les bolchéviks ont inventé
un langage nouveau et il s'estimait
qu'ils vont transformer des valeurs
mais pour le moment on se rappelle avec
un peu de confusion ces tentatives
depuis leur tendre enfance
on dit aux enfants qu'il n'ya pas de
différence entre les genres entre les
sexes et on impose la notion des parents
mères et pères on ne demande pas le
conseil des psychologues d'enfants mais
est ce que un enfant peut prendre une
décision à cet âge là
on
devrait quand même choisir les grandes
valeurs qui sont des valeurs humaines
humaine et est ce qu'on peut parler du
progrès dans ce cas
j'avais déjà dit une fois que en mettant
en place une
perception des choses je veux dit que
c'était une sorte de
conservatisme et et à ce moment là les
passions sur l'arène internationale
s'étaient déchaînés mais peut-être pas
autant que maintenant mais aujourd'hui
alors que le monde est en pleine rupture
on voit que le conservatisme
correspond à une demande aujourd'hui
face aux risques qui se multiplient aux
menaces de notre environnement et la
proche conservatisme du conservatisme
permet de maintenir de préserver un
certain nombre d'éléments importants
mais c'est avant tout un moyen
d'envisager l'avenir sur la base des
traditions de préserver la population de
faire preuve de réalisme vis-à-vis de
soi et des autres de d'établir des
priorités
de formuler les objectifs
et le refus de tout extrémisme
disons le franchement
dans cette période de restructuration
qui vient et qui pourrait durer un
certain temps et dont on ne connaît
évidemment pas l'issue et la fin l'idée
du conservatisme me paraît la plus
raisonnable et
évidemment elle va évoluer mais pour
l'instant
le principe des médecins de ne pas faire
de mal me paraît aujourd'hui le plus
important
je le répète pour nous en russie
ce n'est pas une construction abstrait
abstraite mais c'est sur la base des
événements que nous avons connu dans
l'histoire
face aux éléments qui peuvent détruire
les sens de la société décence morale
face à des ruines sur lesquelles on
pourrait en vain construire nous
comprenons bien que sans coopération
internationale étroite
il ne sera pas possible de résoudre les
problèmes qui se posent aujourd'hui donc
il faut réaliste et la plupart des beaux
slogans de fass
correspondant aux problèmes que nous
entendons depuis la fin du
xxème siècle ne seront pas résolus de
cette façon
aujourd'hui
lorsqu'on voit les systèmes
internationaux
qui s'impose face aux modèles nationaux
donc aujourd'hui il faut trouver les
résultats parce que on répond pas à la
de la façon dont on répond aux menaces
vis-à-vis du monde entier mais vis-à-vis
de nos propres citoyens au niveau
national donc c'est pas une volonté de
limiter
cette optique pour
ne pas supporter ses rangs cette
responsabilité face au monde entier mais
ce que je veux dire c'est que il y a
donc une coopération qui doit se faire
et cela permettra justement de
travailler de façon concrète et pour
stimuler un tel travail il est important
de mettre d'établir au niveau de l'onu
un registre des menaces et défis
et pour ce travail il faut impliquer les
spécialistes de différents pays et de
différentes disciplines scientifiques et
notamment vous chers collègues et c'est
alors que on pourra
porter un regard nouveau sur les défis
qui se posent vis-à-vis du monde et sur
la façon de résoudre ensemble j'ai
évoqué le problème de la crise des
institutions internationales et
malheureusement c'est un fake et deux en
plus évident
et laurent nous avons l'ordre du jour
actuellement surtout c'est la
réorganisation
l'eau est nu en tout cas elle porte sur
les valeurs qui sont stables et jeu dans
ce monde perturbé et je pense que
justement l'onu est le meilleur garant
de
fondement que nous devons utiliser pour
résoudre les questions qui se posent
aujourd'hui en particulier
évidemment ce n'est pas la seule
organisation mais ce sont surtout ses
participants se sont de cette structure
internationale n'est pas seulement une
norme mais elle est aussi l'esprit
qui repose d'ailleurs sur le principe
d'égalité et notre obligation c'est de
réformer tout en maintenant cette
organisation et ce n'est pas la première
fois que je le dis mais je les appelais
depuis des tribunes importante mais ici
à mon avis au forum de valdaï justement
c'est un statut particulier de
discussions mais puisque c'est une
plateforme qui commence à être reconnue
et qui bénéficie d'une certaine autorité
mais le temps
avance et les problèmes s'accumulent et
il faut qu'on travaille de concert et
encore une fois je le dis j'utilise
cette plateforme de discussion pour
manifester notre bonne volonté de
travailler ensemble pour la résolution
des problèmes les plus urgents chers
amis les changements
que qui ont été évoquées avant moi même
et par votre humble serviteur
concerne tous les pays et peuples et la
russie la russie n'est pas ne fait pas
exception ici nous cherchons des
solutions aux problèmes les plus graves
le problème pour lesquels nous n'avons
pas de recette aucun pays n'a de
recettes mais notre pays un certain
nombre d'avantagés je vais expliquer
pourquoi dans notre expérience
historique historique
et je dis d'ailleurs dans cette
intervention bien sûr j'ai dû évoquer un
certain nombre d'éléments négatifs dans
notre histoire mais aujourd'hui il faut
qu'on développe cette immunité
collective contre l'extrémisme est
contre l'échec les gens chez nous en
russie estime la possibilité de pouvoir
se développer ensemble normalement sans
effondrement à l'issue de quelques
révolutions
les gens se souviennent en russie des
événements vieux de 30 ans
qui
avec les après le l'effondrement de
l'urss notre pays avait été dans une
situation de crise de désarroi et nous
avons vu que nous avons permis de voir
nous avons pu voir justement qu'il nous
disposons d'un certain nombre de d'un
certain potentiel et je souhaite à tous
les participants
je remercie de participants pour leur
attention et je serai prêt à au moins
tenté de répondre aux cas vos questions
merci pour votre patience
merci beaucoup monsieur poutine
cette intervention riches sont pas
uniquement concernant lé problème
politique actuelle mais aussi
chose fondamentale
je ne peux pas m'empêcher de demander
vous avez prononcé à plusieurs reprises
les idées de l'expérience historique des
traditions du conservatisme
conservatisme
qui est bon est ce que le conservatisme
ma mauvais nous lui fait pas peur
comment distinguer nos bons
conservatisme du mauvais et où cette
tradition se transforme en fardeau qui
se commet s'apaiser
on peut transformer
n'importe quoi en objet négatif et quand
je parle de conservatisme st je me
souviens toujours de nikolay zherdev
notre philosophe notre éminent
philosophe
et qui avaient été expulsés du rss en
et qui part
tout son être tout son être
orientées vers l'avenir qui lui aussi
était orientée vers le conservatisme
je vais peut-être pas citées exactement
ça ce qu'il avait dit ni david et
du conservatisme c'est parce qu'ils
empêchent d'avancer mais en tout cas
c'est ce qui empêche de revenir en
arrière vers le causse or si on conçoit
le conservatisme de cette façon à ce
moment là oui c'est un bon motif et
c'est une bonne façon d'aller de l'avant
et si on parle de tradition
dans notre société
traditionnelle
la tradition c'est justement quelque
chose unique national comment peut-on
s'unit
traditions différentes vous savez que en
fait il ya un grand nombre de
particularités et de très particulier
dans chaque peuple partout dans le monde
mais il ya toujours quelque chose qui
unit tous tout le monde tous les gens
c'est la valeur de la vie la vie est une
valeur absolue et à mon avis
c'est la même chose si on parle de la
famille la valeur de la famille c'est la
base de la prolongation 2
l'essence de l'être de la vie est ce que
nous voulons être est ce que nous ne
voulons pas être alors si on ne voulons
pas bon d'accord ce moment-là s'y
adapter c'est bien
mais pour adapter un enfant faut d'abord
le mettre au monde
ça c'est une valeur universelle
après il y en ad'autres je ne vais pas
les énumérer vous les connaissez tous et
vous en particulier mais
sur la base de ces valeurs humaines que
nous avons en commun
c'est sûr cela qu'on peut travailler
ensemble
phrase très forte
mondiaux beaucoup de personnes le 10 mai
vous référer à notre expérience du 20e
siècle
sont
pas bien
venir
jeudi qu' il n'y a pas de recette toute
faite mais
ce que nous observons aujourd'hui par
exemple sur le marché de l'énergie on va
en parler je pense encore mais justement
là on a une manifestation de ce
capitalisme qui ne marche pas regardez
la régulation du marché d'accord
mais d'accord 1500
2000 dollars pour mille mètres cubes oui
d'accord de gaz alors quand tout va bien
et tout et tout est stable
presque dans toutes les économies du
monde
tous les participants de l'activité
économique
veulent plus de liberté et moins
d'intervention de l'état dans l'économie
dès que les difficultés
apparaissent surtout si ce sont des
difficultés d'ordre mondial tout le
monde tout de suite s'adresse
exige de l'état qu'il intervienne je me
souviens très très bien en
2008 2009 quand il ya eu cette crise
financière dans le monde
j'étais à ce moment-là premier ministre
russe j'ai eu des discussions avec
un certain nombre de
l'entrepreneur qui réussissait qui
réussit c'est aujourd'hui
qu'ils étaient prêts à céder pour un
rouble des entreprises qui valait des
centaines de milliers de millions
pourquoi parce que il s'agissait ici de
conserver d'assumer la responsabilité de
l'avenir de système alors ils voudraient
ils voulaient au compteur se débarrasser
de cette responsabilité
il voulait que l'état mette son épaule
pursuit mais
il voulait que nous est
que nous les fassions un certain nombre
de dettes etc bon finalement on a trouvé
un certain nombre de solutions
et le plus grandes entreprises nous
avons pu le sauver et l'état le même à
gagner réellement se dire que l'état a
gagné beaucoup d'argent c'est à dire que
quand les entreprises revenait sur pied
à son nom la part de l'état augmenté et
le bénéfice de l'état augmentait
ici
il faut chercher justement regarder
l'expérience des autres pays
l'expérience positive dans d'autres pays
pour pouvoir comparer les potentialités
que nous avons l'état du marché est
l'exemple le plus flagrant c'est celui
de la chine
avec le rôle moteur du parti communiste
qui se maintient les institutions du
marché de l'état du marché fonctionne
donc ya pas de recette toute faite
le capitalisme sauvage ne fonctionne pas
non plus je les dis et je suis prêt le
redire et les exemples que je viens de
citer ne font que le confirmer mais vous
savez c'est un petit peu comme comme par
exemple
dans l'art par exemple
il faut comprendre il faut sentir
percevoir
à quel moment est-ce qu'on va ajouter un
peu plus de sucre un peu plus de sel
est là quand on voit aujourd'hui
les organisations financières le fonds
monétaire international la banque
mondiale et c'est à regarder on regarde
tout ça
il ya les différentes possibilités
de travailler sur nos plans sur nos
projets
et justement d'ailleurs
ces dernières années
et notamment en matière de
de résolution du plan de pandémie nous
avons quand même un certain nombre de
résultats positifs et le résultat n'est
pas mauvais si j'ai bien compris
conservatisme
d'autres choses vous savez nous devons
construire l'état social bien sûr en
europe en europe du nord on en parle
depuis longtemps il faut construire
l'état social mais pour nous c'est
particulièrement important je parle
de cet écart dans
les bénéfices des différentes familles
heures c'est la même chose en europe aux
états-unis un peu plus un peu plus il y
a le climat
tout ce qui se passait auparavant
de peu de gens en ont profité qui ont
multiplié leur fortune tandis que la
classe moyenne et les plus pauvres ont
souffert
ça c'est un problème
aux états unis en europe peut-être
moins mais quand même on le voit merci
la dernière question de ma part pour ne
pas au
combat que la salle souffre trop vous
avez parlé de l'organisation iran du
rôle irremplaçable de l'organisation des
nations unies c'est clair c'est la base
et tout ça mais l'organisation des
nations-unies est très critiquée vous
l'avez mentionné vous aussi
le précédent de la turquie monsieur
erdogan que vous connaissez très bien a
dit récemment que le conseil de sécurité
doit être
doit se transformer parce que les pays
vainqueurs de la seconde guerre mondiale
ou mobilisés monopoliser le pouvoir tout
d'accord non le président erdogan vient
de visiter
la russie
je lui ai dit que j'ai vu l'écran des
lignes de son livre les grandes idées je
suis solidaire avec quelques idées c'est
un très bon analysé et je comprends très
bien pourquoi le président turc en parle
parce que il considère que la turquie
pourrait également le membre permanent
du conseil de sécurité
mais c'est pas de décider à la russie
mais il nous faut un consensus
en déterminant
la composition du conseil de sécurité
nous avons l'est de l'afrique du sud lui
c'est juste mais comment trouver
l'équilibré
là des différentes des solutions sont
possibles je ne vais pas anticiper
même la position de la russie sur ce
sujet mais ce qui est important
et je les dis dans mon mot
d'introduction je les dis au président
turc 1 si on va détruire le droit de
veto des membres permanents dans ce cas
les nations unies vont mourir le jour
même ce sera la ligue des nations tout
simplement de quelque sorte de
une plateforme de discussion pas plus le
forum de valdaï numéro 2
le forum de valdaï numéro un il est ici
le deuxième sera à new york on va partir
à new york peut-être mais je ne voudrais
pas changer quelque chose détruire
quelque chose les bases c'est le sens
des nations unies nous avons cinq
membres permanents de
je vis du droit de veto mais on trouve
dans le concept de sécurité d'autres
pays qui ne sont pas membres permanents
mais il faut réfléchir comment faire
pour que cette organisation soit plus
équilibré il est vrai que
là le président erdogan a raison les
nations unies ont honte
hérité de ce partage de force après la
seconde guerre mondiale mais tout a
changé nos savons très bien par exemple
la chine de la barre du pouvoir d'achat
a dépassé les états unis ça ce sont des
changements globaux qu'on observe tandis
que l'inde par exemple
là aussi il y à un milliard et demi
d'habitants avec un grand développement
de l'économie l'afrique n'est pas
représenté l'afrique du sud n'est pas
représentée il y a le géant dans ce
conte sur ce continent le brésil mais il
ne faut pas précipiter les choses pour
éviter les erreurs
la direction du club valdaï va examiner
la question de la tenue de sessions à
new york j'ai peur que l'on ne tienne
pas de bizarre d'ailleurs pourquoi pas
nos vies le club de valdaï à new york
mettez vous d'accord avec mes cheveux je
pense
qu'au niveau des chefs d'état on va
régler le problème avec monsieur là
bravo va pas il va parler avec les
collègues pourquoi pas tenir le forum de
valdaï sur la plateforme neutre
en dehors de la fédération de russie
c'est possible il y a de l'intérêt pour
cela
il y a des crans experts que se réunisse
qui sont très connus dans leur pays
respectif pour attirer d'autres
personnes
qui pourraient nous rejoindre dans leur
pays respectif c'est très bien
bon l'objectif est fixé un cher ami je
vous en prie c'est pas l'objectif c'est
une opportunité
tout comme la crise c'est une
éventualité
je vous en prie pas beaucoup de qualités
prenez le micro s'il vous plaît
monsieur poutine
je voudrais pour un moment
m'adresser à vos paroles me référer à
vos paroles vous venez de dire que la
russie doit s'appuyer sur les valeurs us
vous en avait parlé
avant-hier
parlé hier et si parmi les penseurs
écrivains russes parmi les
anthropologues vous vous êtes plus
proche pour vous pour que vous
définissiez la valeur pour que sa valeur
soit universel pour l'ajouter
je ne voudrais pas que voilà ivan iline
par exemple lui gelé les oeuvres dit
line j'ai ce livre
que je fais yacht de temps en temps
berdiaev d'autres penseurs également
russe
ce sont des gens qui pensent et de la
russie de l'avenir de la russie
et bien sûr un
faisant référence à cette époque tout en
faisant des réserves mais je me suis
intéressé à ces idées comment il est
réfléchi c'est
leur façon de penser
par exemple une idée de passionna risme
de la nation c'est une idée très
intéressante
on peut contester ses études et eon le
contexte toujours
mais les idées qui ont été formulées au
font l'objet des discussions se sont
tenues ce ne sont pas donc décidé 20 m
par exemple une idée à savoir
les peuples et les nations
les ethnies à l'instar de nos organismes
vivants naissent
évoluer ensuite il y a le déclin
dans de nombreux pays par exemple sur le
continent américain
on dit que il y a le déclin européen
le terme du déclin est utilisé donc
si c'est ça
c'est comme ça au pas je ne sais pas
mais à l'intérieur de la nation vous
avez besoin d'un mobile de développement
la volonté pour le développement
l'autodétermination et cette idée
a toutes les raisons d'être
et
nono voyons qu'il y a l'essor dans
certains pays il ya beaucoup de
problèmes là de là dedans mais il ya une
sorte de volcans qui est est en pleine
ébullition comme sur les îles canaries
il y à l'éruption du volcan mais il ya
d'autres pays qui connaissent un certain
déclin
peut-être quelques chants d'oiseaux pas
plus
je vous en prie
monsieur poutine vous avez mentionné
me love bien sûr
j'ai reçu de sa part à saint-pétersbourg
en 1979
livre notre ca 1er son premier livre je
vais vous transmettre c'est beaucoup
mais ça ça très intéressant merci qu'une
tradition voilà donc chers amis
présentez vous s'il vous plaît quand
vous prenez la parole alexis munoz
jour monsieur poutine
alexei muller historien université
européenne de saint pétersbourg où il y
a deux ans nous avons deux alexeï miller
mais la russie est très riche
il y a deux ans on vous a demandé
pendant la réunion un petit club de
valdaï
concernant la résolution du parlement
européen
où l'union soviétique et bien sûr la
russie
était
s'est vu attribuer les responsabilités
pour les événements qui se sont passés
avec l'allemagne et depuis vous vous
êtes référer à ce sujet et dans votre
article qui est sorti en été en 2020 et
parmi d'autres quand vous avez inauguré
le monument aux victimes du siège en
janvier 2020 vous avez dit que vous
proposeriez une rencontre des leaders
du ps anc pour entre autres abordé ce
sujet
pour justement sortir de ce régime de
compassion de la guerre de mémoire mais
depuis si je ne me trompe pas rien ne
s'est amélioré
peut-être que vous savez quelque chose
ce qui n'a pas connu du grand public
peut-être quelques changements vers le
meilleur vers le mieux il serait bien si
vous en parliez pas reliés et une autre
en question comme il ya cette
confrontation à l'intérieur des pays
qui sont impliquées dans cette guerre de
mémoire
il y a toujours une tentation de serrer
les rangs et dans un certain sens de
restreindre plus ou moins de limiter la
liberté des discussions d'expression des
historiens y compris ces discussions
prévoit toujours des divergences il ya
bien sûr quelques différences même des
avis risque et on dirait des avis en
correct en ce qui concerne notre pays
est ce que vous voyez cette menace
les limites de cette liberté non
il n'y a pas de menace et
de cette façon il ya la menace d'
irresponsabilité pour ses paroles
mais c'est le côté qu'on inverse de
cette liberté si je parle de mon
initiative de tenir
le sommet des
responsables des cinq pays membres
permanents du conseil de sécurité de
cette initiative a été soutenue par tout
le monde mais il ya eu des problèmes qui
n'étaient pas liées à la russie s'était
lié à
avec quelques divergences à l'intérieur
de ces cinq pays et deuxième chose
ensuite c'était la pandémie qui a
compliqué les choses mais cette idée du
sommet
existe qui a reçu une réaction positive
et j'espère que
d'une façon ou d'une autre on va tenir
ce sommet on en parle avec nos
partenaires américains nos amis chinois
avec les français le président français
l'a soutenu tout de suite
et la grande bretagne également
là il ya toutes sortes de propositions
d'idées pour le contenu de
ce sommet mais cette idée a été soutenue
généralement et j'espère qu'on va tenir
ce sommet ultérieurement concernant la
mémoire
historique en général
ce qui est lié à la seconde guerre
mondiale vous savez bien sûr
je suis prête à en parler
avancé des arguments
nous avons beaucoup de questions à poser
aux dirigeants des pays
depuis
à
1990 mais
on peut pas mettre sur
la même planche les nazis et l'équipe
communiste et et partager la
responsabilité à 50 à 50 et c'est le
mensonge je le dis non pas parce que je
suis le ruz et je suis le président
russe la russie hérite
tout ce qui concerne les droits de
l'union soviétique mais je le dis en
tant que chercheur j'ai lu des documents
g
le lieu des documents qui sont issus des
archives et croyez moi quand je lis ces
documents
j'ai une autre image des événements
historiques
oui bien sûr un
staline organiser des camps mais
j'ai vu les résolutions de staline le
gouvernement soviétique
lutter pour prévenir la seconde guerre
mondiale pour des multiples raisons on
pourrait dire que l'union soviétique
n'était pas prête mais l'union
soviétique essayé de prévenir la seconde
guerre mondiale préserver la
tchécoslovaque tchécoslovaquie on posait
la question de défense de la
souveraineté de la tchécoslovaquie j'ai
lu et ces documents
qui ne sont pas confidentielles pour le
moment qu'ils sont déclassées quelle
était la réaction de la france par
exemple à l'époque y compris
en ce qui concerne
la rencontre de munich de 38 avec hitler
cette rencontre des dirigeants européens
avec hitler de 38 et quand on lui ces
documents on comprend
que la tentative de
déformer les l'histoire on le comprend
mais s'il vous plaît lisez et ses
documents je comprends les dirigeants
polonais aujourd'hui qui parle des
événements de 39 mais quand on leur dit
s'il vous plaît regardez tout ce qui se
passait auparavant
vous avez participé ensemble avec
l'allemagne à la division de la
tchécoslovaquie vous avait attisé cet
incendie
et j'ai lu
et les archives
qui était en position de l'union
soviétique
après le passage de l'armée rouge les
documents français polonais allemands
nous sommes en possession de ces
documents et
j'ai vu qu'on qu'il y avait une entente
sur la division de la tchécoslovaquie de
l'autre des troupes dans ce pays et côté
c'était le fait ce sont les faits
historiques et puis on déballe tout et
on dit que c'est la responsabilité de
l'union soviétique seule union
soviétique ce n'est pas la réalité
historique
pour dire simple qui a agressé kiki
était agresseur est ce que c'était
l'union soviétique et agressé
l'allemagne non
oui
il ya eu
des ententes confidentielles entre
l'allemagne et l'union soviétique mais
je porte votre attention
que les troupes russes
sont entrés à brest quand les troupes
allemandes étaient là en place
et ce n'est qu'après la l'armée rouge
est entré il faut pas utiliser au niveau
des experts on pourrait consulter les
documents et voir
personne n'accuse les dirigeants
polonais de l'époque maire on ne permet
pas également d'accuser les dirigeants
soviétiques de l'époque qu'il ya des
choses qui sont évidentes
level 2 juin 40 1
l'allemagne a attaqué l'union soviétique
mais qui a pris berlin est ce que
c'était les américains non c'était des
soviétiques n'ont pas les anglais les
français l'armée rouge qui a pris le qui
a pris berlin est ce qu'on l'a oubliée
une seconde c'est pas compliqué de se
souvenir c'est un fait historique
aux environs de stalingrad nous avons
perdu un million cent mille et en grande
bretagne
la crainte prétend durant toute la
guerre
75% ou bien
80%
d'armes acte a été détruit par l'armée
rouge l'union soviétique
est ce qu'on l'a oublié complètement non
pas du tout tout simplement ils
utilisent
ces événements du passé pour
régler les problèmes intérieurs du
moment c'est mauvais on manipule
l'histoire et
cela n'amène pas à la confiance mutuelle
dont nous avons besoin aujourd'hui
ici s'il vous plaît
quant à l'italie merci pour cette
rencontre comme vous l'avez évoqué
cela fait trente ans
depuis
donc ma question est ce que votre avis
en fait
c'était vrai est ce qu'à votre avis la
russie a surmonté
l'expérience soviétique
en tant que société et qu'est-ce qui est
qu'est ce que vous avez dans votre vie
depuis l'époque soviétique merci
j'écoute attentivement ya beaucoup de
gens de ma génération qui se souviennent
de cette
thèse de cette formulation donc cette
nouvelle identité de l'homme soviétique
nous nous souvenons de tous deux cela
rien de mal dans cette thèse en fait
dans cette énonciation c'est le premier
jeu deuxièmement
regarder tout le monde notamment aux
états unis on parle
d'eux
[Musique]
des états unis comme un melting-pot
celui dans lesquelles est forgé
lançons de la société
ils sont tous fiers de cela qu y at il
de mal a donc les les originaires
d'irlande
d'europe
d'europe de l'est
de n'importe où et même de la tow latino
américains africains et de ceux qui sont
indigènes la plupart d'entre eux sont
fiers d'être citoyen des états unis et
donc ça oui c'est ça c'est se
multiplient mais en fait la russie est
aussi un melting-pot depuis le moment de
l'établissement du
d'un état russe unifiée donc les
premiers pas avaient été entrepris au 8e
19e siècle et après le baptême de la
russie donc
on a eu la nation de rue la nation russe
qui a commencé à se mettre en place avec
l'établissement de l'état avec
en main un seul prince un seul une seule
langue un seul marché et puis des
valeurs spirituelles qui ensuite se sont
élargies se sont étendus et c'était donc
un melting-pot donc rien de nouveau et
l'union soviétique n'a rien créé ici
sauf un point c'est à dire que cette
nouvelle identité de l'homme soviétique
avait aussi une idéologie particulière
or là justement ya rien de bien
puisqu'au contraire ça réduit cette
dimension mais les citoyens soviétiques
ont subi
l'influencé de ces éléments communs
c'est à dire le patriotisme
la supériorité spirituelle sur le
matériel
ce sont les valeurs dont j'ai parlé
notamment la famille et de même que ceux
ci est ajoutée aussi
un aspect
négatif négatif dans la vie de citoyens
c'est à dire que lee dans l'individu
était privé de la de la propriété
notamment au niveau local économique et
donc de la un certain
rapport envers le travail qui a été
malmené donc évidemment l'aï eu un
certain nombre de
d'éléments particuliers qui ont mené
donc à l'effondrement de l'urss
mais
m un coup de noirs surtout ça à mon avis
c'est une erreur et c'est vulgaire etc
c'est indécent chez nous ici en russie
nous avons des gens qui ne qui ne voit
que du noir dans tout cela c'est vrai
mais faut peut-être commencer parle déjà
de quelque chose qui sont mauvais mais
[Musique]
mais il ya aussi il ya autant
d'avantagés que d'inconvénients et dans
ce melting potes qui était qui existait
je considère que c'est bon parce que
c'est un enrichissement pour les gens
pour le peuple et vous savez pour la
russie qu'est ce qu'il ya de si
caractéristique
si on lit justement de documents
historiques et d'ailleurs on le revoit
on le retrouve partout c'est que quand
la russie a étendu son territoire a n'a
jamais mis en situation
déséquilibré les nouveaux peuples qui
faisait partie du peuple russe que ce
soit sur le plan historique ou
confessionnelle regardez ça tant il y
avait toujours cette référence rêve
respecter tout se passe en guinée qui
confesse l'islam et cela a toujours été
et ça c'est une tradition
et en ce sens
si je dis qu'il faut conserver cette
tradition dans la nouvelle donc
je disais justement que dans l'identité
de du de l'homme soviétique il y avait
qu'une chose de mauvaise c'est qu'il y
avait cette idéologie ou mai donc il ya
eu de cette période de l'historique y
étaient difficiles je les
et je l'évoquais peut-être encore une
fois à moi en ce qui me concerne comme
l'écrasante majorité des gens de ma
génération bien évidemment
j'ai été confronté un certain nombre de
problèmes liés à cette période
mais aussi j'ai bénéficié de cette
énergie positive qu'il est impossible
votre humble serviteur
a été diplômé de l'université alors que
je venais du famille de simples
travailleurs j'ai mon diplôme de
l'université de leningrad est-ce que
c'est mal ça non évidemment ce dont tu
sais c'est une réalité sociale qui
existaient
et beaucoup de gens à cette époque là
quand dans le semble le principe
égalisateur
fonctionnaires au sens le plus large de
ce
dans les gens quand les gens étaient
confrontés à ce phénomène de nivee
lisation au niveau du travail
théoriquement en même temps ils ont pu
bénéficier de ce cet ascenseur social et
ça c'est un point important
c'est peut-être l'héritage des
générations d'avant et cela a été
cultivé à l'époque soviétique c'est
important je vais essayer de me souvenir
justement moi je suis mes parents mon
père ma mère était déjà très simple il
parlait pas par ce slogan mais je me
souviens très bien que à la maison tout
simplement dans la vie quotidienne dans
la femme est toujours
et je le souligne toujours
d'une façon ou d'une autre de façon très
simple comme gens du peuple
il avait toujours sur respect pour leur
pays
et s'étaient pas un patriotisme de
façade ce n'était pas du tout mon
patriotisme de façade c'était dans notre
famille c'était quelque chose qui était
intrinsèquement ancrée et je pense avoir
le droit de dire que c'est qualités
positives elle était cultivée dans la
majorité
du peuple et des autres peuples de
l'union soviétique c'est
c'est pour ça que la majorité des gens à
voter pour le maintien de l'urss parce
que la plupart des gens des peuples qui
se sont détachés de la russie ont
regretté et aujourd'hui
les villes
ils se sont développés différemment mais
on respecte ce choix et cette émotion
mais en ce qui concerne l'homme
soviétique comme on disait à l'époque le
mot soviétique hausse
je pense que je me suis exprimé
suffisamment
la première fois
du prix
donner la parole
bonjour merci monsieur le président
chers participants
je voudrais dire que l'argent est bien
réparti
merci
à la fondation
de la
contribution modeste va faire en sorte
que nous allons
aller attention au fait que dans cette
fondation il ya des gens des enfants qui
quand ils deviennent adultes restent
sans aide
nous pensons que la fondation est prête
à élargir son mandat il s'agit d'un
hospice pour les enfants ce maillot
c'est également le premier hospice verra
la fondation a donné la vie c'est au
prix d'un apolit kourskaïa la fondation
en aide aux médias
je pense également que à quelques degrés
ce prix
décerné à notre pays je pense que je
suis un poster dans ce sens là je vais
essayer de faire en sorte que ce prix
servi à notre peuple si vous permettez
un petit répit remarque j'ai étudié
attentivement votre réponse monsieur
poutine a pendant la semaine énergétique
scoop concernant les agents étrangers
que nous ne sommes pas les premiers à
adopter la loi que les états unis
l'avaient fait dans les années 30 mais
puisque monsieur deux précédents nous
n'adoptons pas toutes les lois qui sont
adoptées aux états unis ma question
reste toujours là concernant les agents
étrangers je pense que cela ne concerne
pas uniquement des dizaines et des
dizaines de journalistes de
défenseurs des droits de l'homme qui
figure dans le registre cela comptait
concerne également des centaines des
milliers d'époque ce qu'il disait les
travaux de ces journalistes
vient essentielle c'est que vous venez
de dire
vous avez fait des études dans votre
l'université de leningrad je voudrais
dire que votre éducation vous permettra
de nous comprendre justement cette loi
ne n'ont qu'une pas la justice il n'y a
pas de procès juridique on se nomme un
agent ou en agent étranger il n'y a pas
de procès juridique il n'y a pas de
preuves il n'y a que la stigmatisation
je vous appelle en livres pour les
enfants il s'agit de la même
stigmatisation que de l'estimation 2010
dans les trois mousquetaires mais quand
on coupait la tête à milady on lui a
donné le jugement il ya eu la
condamnation mais là il n'y a pas de
condamnation il n'y a pas de jugement en
plus on ne peut pas sortir de cette loi
il n'y a même pas de prévention
d'avertissement que des le demande tu
deviens un agent étranger
pour beaucoup cela veut dire un ennemi
du peuple je me rappelle
que dans la charte du service il faut
d'abord faire en coup de semonce
sans ce coup de semonce
ce nom qu'on voit dans les camps tirant
sur les gens
je pense qu'il nous faut
qu'il nous faut régler ce problème parce
qu'il ya des critères très flou
par exemple la réception dead
organisationnel et méthodique qui est ce
que cela veut dire c'est à dire que
maintenant je prends en commentaires
d'un membre du club de valdaï c'est les
représentants d'un autre y est
et nous sommes des agents étrangers
vendredi le dise je vous rappelle que
d'annoncer justement vendredi
je tiens à vous demander à réagir
faut réagir à cette question mais
peut-être que vous monsieur poutine
ensemble avec par exemple le président
de la douma d'état
vous allez organiser une rencontre
extraordinaire avec des représentants
des médias différence pour que nous
puissions aborder les questions
qui sont là merci beaucoup
tout d'abord je tiens vous féliciter
d'avoir de vous être
d'avoir été
honoré du prix de la peine de nouvelles
de la paix vous avez évoqué
berdyev
et sa candidature avait été donnée
justement pour le prix nobel de la paix
est en fait il ne l'a pas eu
qu'est ce que ça peut faire
en littérature ben may d'accord le prix
nobel de la paix a été remis
au premier président de
l'urss dans votre chef vous à barack
obama donc vous êtes en bonne compagnie
mais en effet oui nous savons vous avez
bien parler et
pour ce que vous faites pour le travail
noble que vous faites je moi je vous le
remettrait le prix de la paix et le
cercle du bien et c'est votre
préoccupation à propos des agents de
l'étranger
je vais pas
exact je veux dire directement ici quand
ces décisions sont prises
premièrement la loi mais est-ce que nous
il faut qu'on en prenne emprunte tout
aux américains non non pas tout
mais en russie il y à beaucoup de gens
de point de vue libéral qui nous
appellent à copier tout ce qui vient des
mannequins or je suis d'accord et vous
pas tout non
vous avez dit que ce n'est pas
par les états unis ou séparés c'est pas
sur décision de justice
demandez à rhj et hôtels ce qui se passe
donc c'est effectivement très dure
jusqu'à responsabilité pénale or chez
nous y'a pas ça la question n'est pas de
savoir la position de tel ou tel
acteurs publics de tels médias
c'est pas l'heure question de position
on leur interdit pas d'avoir leur propre
opinion sur telle ou telle cette loi et
les à
la réception de soutien financier de
l'étranger au cours de l'activité
politique c'est de ça qu'il s'agit et
cette loi n'interdit pas de poursuivre
cette activité politique mais cet argent
qui est reçue de derrière les frontières
doit il faut que cet argent soit
affichée on sait que cette personne et
non telle position il intervient dans la
vie politique interne etc mais il reçoit
de l'argent de l'étranger c'est ça c'est
le droit de la société russe et tours et
n'essayaient pas de lettre de
restriction au delà de ça
et quand vous avez dit qu'
il n'y a pas de jugement effectivement
il n'ya pas de jugement
l'appât du jugement point d'être coupé
la tête et là ya pas de jugement et vous
pourrez continuer à travailler
et donc là où vous avez raison
n'ai je vais pas contester parce que
c'est vrai bien sûr il faut encore une
fois et je vous le promets nous allons
encore ces critères qui sont floues
je sais qu'il ya des cas et moi ça me
concerne
personnellement mes amis personnellement
qui sont impliqués dans les actions
caritatives qui se retrouve avec le
statut d'agent de l'étranger
et je sais qu'avec eux on en a parlé au
conseil des droits de l'homme mais je
donne justement des ordres à
l'administration pour que
on revienne sur cet instrument et qu'on
le perfectionne et qu'on en abuse pas
est ce que vous avez dit encore une fois
vous avez attiré votre attention là
dessus oui je vous remercie et on va
s'en occuper merci beaucoup
oui
oui c'est pas une c'est une grande
organisation je ne connais pas tous les
gens mais quand j'étais directeur vie je
consultais leur dossier je ne connais
pas tout le monde maintenant
être vigilant et ne pas être vigilant du
touch qui centre
non non
non il ne s'agit pas de répression de
masse non bien sûr
il n'y a pas
de cette procédure de masse pour appeler
tellement des agents de l'étranger non
non
vous exagérez le danger de cette
procédure
l'apparition de cette loi est expliquée
par mois tout à l'heure
oui merci bonjour nous sommes agents
étrangers depuis longtemps déjà en plus
je doit comparaître aux états unis
parce que nous n'étions pas enregistrer
en tant qu'agent de l'étrangère
auparavant malgré le fait que tout le
juriste y compris
des employés de haut rang du ministère
de la justice je te dis d'ailleurs
je t'ai licitation encore une fois
malgré le fait que ces juristes ont
travaillé nous avons des conclusions par
écrit que nous ne sommes pas agent ou de
l'étranger parce qu'il y avait été écrit
en anglais outre les médias sauf les
médias madonna quand notre public cette
énergie ils ont dit que peu importe ce
que dit le ministère de la justice soit
vous vous vous enregistrez soit vous
devez être emprisonnés je doit
comparaître parce que je n'étais pas
enregistré avant qu'ils les enregistrent
donc je n'y vais pas au cas où parce que
probablement je vais être emprisonné là
bas c'est le premier point
est bien sûr la prison ne peut attendre
had à tout moment cinq ans de prison
nous connaissons des personnes qui sont
emprisonnés selon cette loi
ils doivent être emprisonné pendant cinq
ans deuxièmement cette loi enfin
introduire des sanctions et de
conséquence par exemple on retire dans
l'accréditation est comme si on n'a pas
de connotation au congrès aux etats unis
tu ne peux plus aller nulle part ni
signèrent d'autres événements nulle part
il ya des gens qui affirment ce que je
dis on travaille de façon clandestine on
travaille depuis six ans on va
poursuivre nos travaux monsieur poutine
je voudrais vous remercier pour votre
conservatisme sens en tant que mère de
trois petits enfants parce que je me
crois beaucoup à la pensée que mon fils
va être proposé de choisir son sexe son
genre avec ma fille
à l'école comme c'est fait dans beaucoup
de pays occidentaux
on va lui dire que c'est une personne
qui va mettre au monde un enfant qui va
être une personne avec du lait humain et
que c'est tentacules du fascisme libéral
devons attendre nos impôts j'espère que
ça ne sera pas le cas dans d'autres pays
malgré son ouverture vraiment très large
vous avez parlé du bavardage
soi-disant la base humaniste de la
pensée européenne
mais en fait le bavardage c'était la soi
disant liberté d'expression la liberté
d'expression c'était une petite carte
postale qui a été dessiné pour des
personnes comme nous années 90 pour que
nous les regardions et pensions ah ben
c'est bien ça existe nous n'aurons pas
d'agent de l'étranger tout sera bien
conquis cette liberté d'expression
justement suffoquer être anglais notre
chaîne youtube qui était très populaire
tout était vraiment très cool là bas
vous savez très bien que ce n'est pas
une chose clandestine c'est un projet
étatique que nous avons créée pour nous
pour la patrie mais nous avons épuisé
nos opportunités pour faire revenir ce
projet nous ne croyons plus rien sauf
les mesures réciproques
il y a eu des classements
mais des médias qui ne sont pas
tellement populaire que nous ne peuvent
pas une qui peuvent diffuser leurs
contenus tandis que nous ne pouvons pas
le faire
nous avons beaucoup travaillé et
maintenant sans jugement dima je me
réfère à toi sans jugement
en une seconde sans aucun fondement
notre détruit tout ce travail ce n'est
pas la question c'est juste un grande
demande protège genoux je ne vois aucune
autre protection sauf les mesures
réciproques ma question
il y a eu le congrès de compatriotes hoh
moscou vous avez envoyé votre message
navigation et moi aussi je suis
intervenu ou là bas et j'ai demandé aux
collègues qui étaient là bas il s'agit
de personnes qui protège activement ou
la langue russe dans les pays du monde
qui risquent parfois leur vie leur
liberté
je voudrais demander à ces personnes de
lever les manques qui voudraient obtenir
la nationalité russe mais qui ne pouvait
pas le faire et la moitié de la salle et
enlevaient leurs mains nous en parlons
beaucoup mais il ya quelques temps où
nous avons parlé de la nationalité pour
les citoyens du donbass aujourd'hui en
effet la procédure avait beaucoup pas
sous pli facilité mais est-ce qu'on peut
faciliter et assouplir cette procédure
pour plus de personnes les juifs les
grecs personne n'a pas hésité à le faire
mais nous nous hésitons
voilà ma question merci
les premières choses
concernant les mesures de rétorsion je
crois que il faut être prêt dans
si quelqu'un quelque part commet des
erreurs de cette sorte et je crois que
ce sont des erreurs quand il s'agit de
la fermeture d'une chaîne
ou bien des conditions qui ne vous
permettent pas de travailler je connais
cette histoire de fermeture des comptes
il ya toutes sortes d'outils la
wii c'est un comportement tapis bien sûr
oui je le sais
mais bien sûr ce sont des limitations de
la liberté d'expression mais
il faut réfléchir
il faut parler à tout le monde qu'on
vous interdis et l'intérêt va connaître
la hausse oui je vous contre je me
comprends
je ne comprends mais il faut y réfléchir
les opportunités techniques
technologiques concernant les mesures de
rétorsion je répète pour que ces mesures
ne soient pas contre-productive je ne
suis pas contre mais il faut quand même
être prudent
concernant la nationalité russe vous
avez raison
la position ma propre position est
simple
il faut perfectionner cet outil
juridique
il ya des questions qui sont liées à des
composantes socio économique de cette
procédure
les hôpitaux les maternités les emplois
et j'en passe
l'habitat ush où habitait la question se
pose pour ces gens là mais la loi sur la
nationalité doit être plus libérale
c'est évidemment et c'est évident c'est
l'exigence du marché de travail
depuis longtemps que tu conseilles
d'être recherche
ont pris la parole
merci fadeur
je regrette beaucoup
pas pouvoir être présent à cette
conférence
voir tous les participants mais c'est un
plaisir
de vous rejoindre
le thème des discussions actuelles pose
des questions fondamentales
je suis ravi de pouvoir participer à ces
discussions monsieur le président
à examiner avec sagesse n'est question
qui figure sur un ordre du jour
ma question est
pour moi pour mon pays cette question
très importante
ni votre gouvernement mis
l'administration de joe biden
parce
que là la relance des relations est
possible à votre avis
quelle sera l'évolution des relations
après votre rencontre avec le président
joe biden en jouant
donc quels domaines y at-il de progrès
s'il y en a
et quels sont à votre avis les obstacles
majeurs dans la voie vers le progrès
futurs merci
en général j'ai déjà répondu à ces
questions je peux
reprendre mes réponses mais je peux
également donné des éléments de tout ce
qui se passe aujourd'hui
la rencontre à genève
était productive en général
et nous avons eu l'impression je parle
de mes collègues également qu en général
l'administration américaine
voudrait faire renaître mais nos
relations dans beaucoup de domaines
nous nous sommes entendus sur le début
des consultations sur la stabilité
stratégique
et ses consultations sont en cours
actuellement et les questions de la
cybersécurité au niveau des experts ça
se fait maintenant et je constate
en toute franchise
que la totalité des questions
qui ont fait l'objet de l'entente de
n'est pas grande mais nous sommes sur la
bonne voie c'est très bien aujourd'hui
et l'administration américaine
aujourd'hui ainsi que la russie de notre
côté
met en oeuvre les projets que nous avons
dressé et c'est un bon signal
un signal systémique
et nous avons déjà
constaté la hausse de 23 % de nos
échanges commerciaux dans plusieurs
domaines
c'est le témoignage
de la conséquence indirecte de notre
rencontre à genève nous avons entamé
donc une bonne voie mais malheureusement
nous voyons une sorte de
régression
comme on disait à l'époque un pas en
avant deux pas en arrière mais nos
progrès sont quand même dans certains
domaines c'est comme ça
ap chers collègues que vous pouvez
entamer la visioconférence
c'est un grand honneur que vous posez la
question
d'abord
remercier pour cette opportunité
je voudrais vous poser une question sur
l'afghanistan
concrètement
sur le fait que l'organisation de
coopération de shanghai à bord d'une
question
et ne cesse aux problèmes
des américains
retirer leurs troupes de l'afghanistan
et maintenant
qui réunit la chine d'autres pays
comment ocs peut aider l'afghanistan à
attendre une stabilité politique et le
développement économique merci
c'est une des questions très aigu de
l'actualité vous savez que
nous avons eu
une rencontre le format de moscou
avec les représentants du taliban tout à
l'heure un
la république populaire de chine
travaille dans cette direction
à regarder de façon active pour nous
tous cela revêt
une importance primordiale
pour la chine pour la russie il est très
important d'avoir
à côté de nos frontières nationales
l'afghanistan visible qui se développe
qui n'est pas une source de terrorisme
du radicalisme de toutes sortes nous
voyons tout ce qui se passe à
l'intérieur de l'afghanistan
malheureusement
la ya toujours une président présence
des groupements de l'état islamique il
ya des victimes parmi le mouvement de
tous les banquiers en général et on le
voit essayez quand même
deux
détruire ces groupements terroristes
c'est très important pour la chine et la
russie pour normaliser la situation
il faut bien sûr aider l'afghanistan à
rétablir son économie parce que notre
problème ce sont les drogues le trafic
de drogue
85%
de drogue arrive
de l'afghanistan sur le marché du trafic
de drogue cela dit bien sûr avec toute
cette importance et de notre
participation dans ce processus de la
russie de la chine et d'autres pays de
l'organisation de coopération de
shanghai la grande responsabilité est
assumée par les pays qui ont fait la
guerre là dessus et la première chose
qu'il fallait faire c'est le dégel des
avoirs afghans et donner la possibilité
à ce pays de régler leur possible leurs
problèmes socio économiques de notre
côté
nous avons deux les grands projets
dans ce pays il y a des problèmes
de garantie de notre propre sécurité nos
services de sécurité sont en contact
avec les services afghans et dans le
cadre de l'organisation de coopération
de shanghai il est important de mettre
en place ce travail
nous avons le tadjikistan l'ouzbékistan
qui sont des pays frontaliers
qui ont une frontière commune avec
l'afghanistan nous avons notre base
militaire au tadjikistan à la base de
notre
201e division
de l'époque soviétique
nous allons continuer ce travail avec la
chine
et en coopération avec des structures en
question et en général dans le cadre de
l'organisation de coopération de
shanghai on va le faire en débloquant
des ressources nécessaires et en créant
les conditions pour que les citoyens de
nos propres pays sera en sécurité et eux
indépendamment de tout ce qui se passe
en afghanistan
merci fodor merci monsieur poutine
j'aurais essayé de reposer une question
la réponse à laquelle je suis sur une
frappe tendue par des centaines de
milliers de personnes sur la patrie vous
avez mentionné un proverbe chinois
disons qu'il est
d'entendre l'époque de vivre à l'époque
des changements mais notre pays traverse
un changement ou de façon continue et
cette période d'autant plus dure qu'il y
à la colline
il ya aussi les américains il y a
quelques jours nous avons
ministre de la défense austin qui est
appliqué à apporter plusieurs millions
de dollars des armes qui a promis un
avenir clair
je vais marquer tout de suite que
les conversations concernant l'otan et
son actualité vous europe1 fr d'accord
mais je pense que ce n'est pas pertinent
il n'est pas obligatoire d'être un
membre de l'otan pour placer déployer
l'infrastructure militaire britannique
et s'interroge sur le territoire
ukrainien je pense que ce processus
vient de commencer de facto dans un
article de juillet sur l'unité
historique vous avez écrit que la
transformation de l'ukraine
qui russie
étienne acceptable pour des millions de
personnes c'est vrai les sondages ne
montrent alors confié en plus de 40 %
ont une attitude très positive ou
positive vis-à-vis de la russie et cette
transformation commence en fait
une grande partie de la voie était déjà
dépassée
je pense que si cette histoire avec
l'infrastructure de l'otan
sera émise en oeuvre alors le processus
de la formation
du monde entier aussi qu'il n'a pas très
stable pour l'instant va être
consolidées pour des années à venir dans
votre article vous avez écrit que si ce
processus continu de cela va représenter
une lourde menace à l'état russe et cela
peut comporter des risques on peut
perdre l'étatisme ukrainiens ou du
catholicos tous les gens qui sont contre
ce mouvement
ils subissent dans la pression ou qu'on
essaie électorale devait choot qu'on
essaie d'emprisonner
ce au nom des accusations tout à fait
absurde
comment peut-on arrêter ce processus
vous avez une idée concernant les délais
qu'est-ce qu'on peut faire un général
merci
malheureusement je vais probablement
vous décevoir parce que je ne connais
pas la réponse à cette question
bien évidemment ça
le plus simple serait de dire que le
peuple ukrainien c'est à lui de prendre
la décision pour
un et un gouvernement qui réponde à ses
attentes d'un côté oui de l'autre
il ya quelque chose et je ne peux pas
le cacher mais devait choke oui vous
avez parlé de lui
on essaie de l'accusé de trahison
nationale
est ce qu'il a volé des secrets est-ce
qu'il a transféré des secrets non
pourquoi là
pour sa position politique ouverte
où il souhaite la stabilisation
politique d'un pays et l'établissement
de bonnes relations avec les voisins
parce que ces relations sont
particulièrement importantes pour le
pays
qu'est ce qui empêche ces gens de lever
la tête certains se font tuer dans la
rue d'autres se font isolé on a donc
l'impression que les moyens légaux dont
dispose le peuple greiner ne lui
permettent pas de
[Musique]
former des organes de victoire qui
permettrait directement aux intérêts du
peuple ukrainien
les gens ont même peur de répondre au
sondage
parce qu'un certain de gens qui se sont
appropriés en fait
les lauriers des de la victoire dans
cette lutte des gens d'opinions
politiques
extrémistes en fait ces gens dirige le
grain
quel que soit
le nom de famille du président du chef
de l'état
on a vu des dirigeants
de pays
qui s'appuyant
je disais défendre les citoyens du
sud-est de l'ukraine et qui changeait
radicalement de position
pourquoi
parce que cette
majorité avait voté espérant que les
leurs espérances
seraient satisfaites
alors que en fait
toutes les toutes ces attentes qui
souhaitait donc
d'une solution pour le pays et donc ces
gens prennent le pouvoir et pour moi
c'est ici une impasse et je vois pas
très bien comment on peut en sortir donc
nous verrons ce qui va se passer sur le
plan politique intérieur en ukraine
prochainement de notre côté nous faisons
tout ce qui dépend de nous pour établir
ces relations
mais cette menace dont vous avez parlé
enfin que vous avez évoqué et que dont
nous parlons
elle existe elle est importante et vous
avez raison de dire que la
participation
formelle au sein de l'otan
n'empêche pas l'établissement de bases
militaires et que effectivement ça crée
une menace pour la fédération de russie
nous en sommes bien conscients
regardez ce qui s'est passé par exemple
à la fin des années 80 au début des
années 90
vous m'avez justement s'était jamais je
n'avais pas l'intention mais on n'avait
que partout on a commencé à dire que
après la réunification de l'allemagne
il n'y aurait
aucun mouvement
des
des structures de l'otan en direction de
l'est pourtant la russie pouvait
certains et dans la pratique qu'est ce
qui s'est passé on nous a trompés
et maintenant on nous dit mon prénom sur
le papier
d'abord ils ont étendu la présence de
l'otan deux ils ont agrandi l'otan elle
même et sur les plans stratégique on
voit cette infrastructure qui soit beau
cette infrastructure qui s'est établi en
pologne en roumanie
c'est quoi cette phrase de ce sont les
systèmes de défense antimissile
c'est à dire que des systèmes son
instinct installé avec des taux moque de
qui sont offensifs équipe il suffit
justement simplement de changer
l'interface électronique et ils peuvent
fonctionner et d'autres missiles peuvent
être de portée
intermédiaire peuvent être installés
aussi est ce que quelqu'un a déclaré
a répondu à nos déclarations sur le fait
que nous allons pas installer de
domicile c'est nous allons pas en
développer sur ce territoire non il n'ya
aucune réponse on ne nous répond pas
on est des adultes on est si tous des
adultes
et qu'est ce qu'on doit faire alors dans
cette situation
par conséquent d'envoyer le ministre de
la défense américain qui est venu
et qui en fait ils ouvrent les portes à
le cren au sein de l'otan et c'est comme
ça qu'il faut l'interpréter c'est à dire
chaque pays a le choix personne ne dit
non aux personnes elles mêmes les
américains dont vous parlez moi j'ai
parlé directement personnellement avec
eux alors aujourd'hui c'est un dirigeant
demain ce sera un autre qui viendra sa
place et alors
c'est pas une garantie de sécurité pour
la russie ce sont simplement des
discussions autour d'un thème donné
et cela évidemment nous préoccupe
en ce qui concerne les bases
je connais les dispositions
constitutionnelles de l'ukraine une
personne interdit d'établir une base de
formation et sous le terme de base de
formation peut mettre n'importe quoi
et ça a été dit publiquement donc demain
près de kharkov des missiles seront
installés et nos questions ce n'est pas
nous qui pratiquons ingérence ici avec
nos missiles on ne les met sous le nez
donc évidemment c'est un pays c'est un
problème
ajuste sa vision stratégique
c'est une approche intéressante
six saisons cette vision
nous allier avec la chine
oui on a beaucoup parlé de cela déjà
sa mamie avec lâché non pas contre
quelqu'un mais dans nos intérêts annoncé
pour la chose deuxième chose
contrairement à l'otan aux pays de
l'otan nous ne créons pas de bloc
militaire fermée il n'y a pas de bloc
militaire
russie chine on n'a pas l'intention d'en
créer un mais la discussion là dessus ne
repose sur rien du tout
déjà parlé mais parfois cela suscite
perplexité
parfois les représentants russes disent
qu'il y a des volumes supplémentaires
qui peuvent être envoyés si on ouvre le
nord stream ii et parfois on dit que il
n'y a pas de gaz supplémentaire qui peut
être envoyé vers l'europe je voudrais
vous demandez peut-être que vous pouvez
préciser s'il ya des volumes de gaz
complémentaires que la russie pourrait
envoyer en europe
s'il honore titre ne commence à être
opérationnels et où il n'ya pas de ce
gaz
je vous dis franchement ça me paraît
même bizarre d'entendre de telles
questions au cours des réponses aux
questions qui sont posées sur lors de la
semaine de l'énergie à moscou tout a été
dit 6
si c'est nécessaire on en parle encore
regardez ce qui se passe
hier ou avant-hier avec le gouvernement
on a parlé de ça le problème c'est pas
seulement les vecteur d'énergie il
s'agit aussi de la situation économique
internationale
regardez la situation dans les pays
développés où on a une pénurie qui
augmente
et donc une décision était prise s
récemment pour augmenter la dette de
l'état mais pour les gens
qui travaillent dans l'économie ça veut
dire simplement qu'on fait fonctionner
la planche à billets
voilà et le gouvernement prend les c de
l'émission monétaire
donc la pénurie augmente et donc on a
une inflation
et donc on a cette émission artificielle
et donc on a une augmentation des prix
sur les vecteurs d'énergie et au
contraire c'est à dire que on a la même
logique la situation s'aggrave encore en
raison des réalités du marché de
l'énergie vous avez parlé de l'europe
oui et je répète certains points
si je me souviens de tout ce que je veux
dire mais
toute la philosophie de ces dernières
années de la commission européenne
visait à réguler le marché des vecteurs
de l'énergie en particulier jets de gaz
par ce qu'on appelle des spots c'est à
dire des bourses et on nous a convaincus
de la nécessité de renoncer aux contrats
à long terme
avec des prix qui soit lié aux cotations
boursière sur le marché pour le pétrole
et les produits pétroliers or on a des
produits des prix qui sont formés sur le
marché et que le produit les prix du gaz
également est influencé par le prix
du
du pétrole et avec un retard de six mois
ça veut dire que le marché est plus
stable et donc les acteurs du marché
peuvent s'orienter peuvent sur ce qui va
se passer donc
tout a commencé à tourner autour de ces
fameux spot mais ces spots c'est pas du
gaz réels c'est-à-dire un volume
physique de gaz mais c'est un gaz sur le
papier s'est inscrit sur le papier il
n'y a pas de volume physique donc ils
sont réduits
il ya l'hiver froid
il y a
l'augmentation du gascon extrait de
terre
il ya l'été
chaud l'absence de génération
le déficit de génération
il ya les raisons macroéconomiques
il y a les caractéristiques sectorielle
et qu'est ce qui se passe sur le marché
européen c'est à dire que la baisse de
production dans les pays extracteur de
gaz cette baisse
a été de
22%
28%
et
il manque 18 milliards de mètres cubes
de gaz
donc tout cela aurait dû être tout ça
c'est pour le premier semestre et si on
regarde les besoins pour l'année entière
on multiplie par deux c'est à dire qu'on
a 9 milliards de mètres cubes de glace
qui sont surtout
d'origine
d'origine américaine et du proche orient
qui ont été supprimées de
de l'europe et qui ont été envoyés en
amérique du sud
et d'ailleurs quand on parle de des
éléments constitutifs
constitutifs du prix pour le marché
européen
on dit que c'est un pays primaire
or aujourd'hui le marché européen n'est
pas primer donc il n'est pas prix mais
aujourd'hui
regardez l'amérique latine
et en asie
je les dis déjà c'est à dire que
18 milliards x 2
- neuf qui manque
sur ce qu'il doit venir des états unis
et du proche orient avec en plus une
baisse de la production de 22 %
on a un déficit qui peut atteindre 70
milliards de mètres cubes de gaz
et la russie allait ou là dedans
donc c'est un russe le résultat concret
de la commission européenne la russie
n'y est absolument pour rien la russie
en particulier gazprom a augmenté ses
livraisons sur le marché européen
gasprom ou dans l'ensemble la augmenté
de
8,7 pour cent
et plus loin à 19 12 pour cent mais
quand on parle de pays étrangers loin ça
concerne aussi la russie par exemple la
chine pardon mais cela est bénéfique
pour le marché mondial puisque nous
augmentons
le volume mondial et pour en valeur
absolue c'est 1,1 c 11 milliards de
mètres cubes supplémentaires les
américains n'ont pas fourni et le
prochain de 9 milliards et nous on a
augmenté gazprom a augmenté de 11
milliards et j'ai ce que j'entends bien
je parle pas de cette salle concrètement
mais jeudi les personnes concernées est
ce qu'elles entendent bien où vous
réduit quelque chose et nous nous
augmentons
mais c'est pas tout
aujourd'hui
sur les contrats à long terme écoutez
moi bien
c'est important je veux que vous
écoutiez là
on avait
1200 $ pour
pour 1100 mètres cubes
les américains
on a face à des prix qui sont quatre
fois inférieurs et gazprom ne reçoit pas
de bénéfice de supplémentaire ici parce
que nous sommes intéressés à des
contrats à long terme et des relations
d' obligations mutuelles à long terme et
à ce moment là nous nous permettons
d'investir dans l'extraction
et d'augmenter donc les volumes pour nos
consommateurs de façon stable et de
façon fiable
est ce qu'il est possible d'augmenter
vous demandez oui c'est possible pour
north stream 2
le premier tuyau est remplie en gaz si
demain le régulateur allemand donne
l'autorisation dé les oiseaux après
demain les livraisons commence
dit 7 milliards 17 5 milliards de mètres
cube donc fin décembre le prix lol les
travaux de remplissage du deuxième tuyau
de nord stream 2 seront achevés au total
ça fait 55 milliards de matricule si on
prend en compte que le déficit sur le
marché européen est de 70 milliards 55
c'est déjà beaucoup
dès que
l'autorisation sera donné par le
régulateur allemand le lendemain nous
commencerons les livraisons
est ce que c'est possible vous avez
demandé oui c'est possible
mais pour cela il faut avoir une
démarche responsable vis-à-vis des
obligations que nous avons les uns vers
les autres et d'ailleurs nous parlons de
north stream de
gazprom gazprom là il ya cinq sociétés
européennes pourquoi gazprom média pas
que gazprom vous avez oublié 5 très
grandes entreprises européennes sont
impliqués dans ce projet
est donc ce n'est pas seulement
l'intérêt de gazprom c'est l'intérêt de
tous nos partenaires et en premier lieu
de nos partenaires européens
ce n'est pas ma décision c'est sa propre
décision
elle pourrait encore représenter sa
candidature
et il était à ce poste saison c'est
important à l'instar de helmut kohl cas
réunit l'allemagne concernant les north
stream on l'a commencée avec monsieur
schröder et à l'époque où il y avait un
projet de north stream 1 1 il y avait
aussi des problèmes
des entraves
heureusement l'allemagne reçoit de gaz
russe par nord stream
des quantités importantes
nous parlons toujours de l'énergie verte
oui c'est très important ici il y aura
des questions je vais formuler
mon point de vue mais notre gaz le gaz
russe
sa composante carbonique est trois fois
moindre que
la composante
carbonique du gnl et mike 1
6e
les spécialiste en écologie
se préoccupe de l'avenir de l'humanité
ils ne peuvent pas l'ignorer
il devrait exiger non pas la fermeture
de tous les terminaux
du gnl peut-être
cela concerne également
le cas ci craignant le nord stream 2
ce sont des technologies modernes des
tubes modernes qui
supporte une grande pression qui passe
par le fond de la mer baltique et
les stations de
de transporteur de gaz et met co2
mais le chiffre et
5,6 fois moins que les émissions qui
viennent des cas ce dieu qui part qui
passe par l'ukraine et les écologistes
pourraient dire qu'il fallait fermer le
transit par une non on nous dit il faut
augmenter le transit par l'ukraine
la même chose se passe dans le pétrole
on abandonne le gaz on en a parlé
longtemps qu est ce qui se passe avec le
pétrole
depuis l'année 2012 à
2016 et les investissements
dans
l'extraction du pétrole ont constitué
environ 400 milliards de dollars par an
et les dernières années avant même la
pandémie ils ont connu la réduction de
30% et constitue seulement 260
millions de dollars mais il y a le chic
halle de 15 à 30 ans
mais oui le problème d'aujourd'hui je
parlais
des composantes politiques de toutes
sortes mais il y a une chose importante
à laquelle je pense les cycles
politiques
dans les grandes économies ne consiste
pas
au cycle d'investissement y compris dans
le domaine des hydrocarbures hall le
domaine et d'orgies le cycle politique
c'est 4 5 ans
les forces politiques essentiel qu'est
ce qu'est ce qu'elles font elles
promettent
il ya toutes sortes de promesses
beaucoup plus c'est moins cher
et cela est lié par exemple à l'énergie
verte mais où sont les résultats
les banques ne critique plus les
investissements les investissements se
réduisent et le moment vient où
le marché
voit exigé de l'argent mais l'argent
n'existe plus même aujourd'hui
opecst plus haut peut plus
augmenter
les volumes d'extraction du pétrole même
plus que convient que conformément à
l'entente mais pas tout le monde est
capable de le faire pas tous les pays
pétroliers parce que il y à une
procédure technologique compliqué à long
terme
il y a le cycle qui dure plusieurs
années
je vous en prie
merci monsieur le président je suis
vraiment ravi de vous voir ici
si j'en appellerai dictateur gamme je
suis content actrice et la directrice
exécutive de l'institution de bergame je
suis venu du liban à sotchi de les
brosser tant pis qui a beaucoup souffert
vous savez qu'il ya eu une explosion
cette explosion est survenue
encore de belles routes ports civile il
ya eu une tentative de mener une enquête
de ce qui s'est passé
le capitaine russe du navire tous les
navires à thé turc je vous demande
monsieur le président
cette question
concerne
la justice de notre pays
le système de justice je vous prie de
bien vouloir partager les images de
satellites pour que nous puissions
voir
ce qui s'est passé réellement
parce que cela a presque détruit notre
capitale est ce que vous êtes prête à
partager les informations à savoir
partager les images de satellites pour
commencer à coopérer dans le cadre de
cette enquête
parce que les valeurs dont vous avez
parlé
ont une importance dans ce cas là
ma deuxième question
porte sur hesbollah et les rangs
aujourd'hui on essaie de destituer le
juge qui mène à une enquête dans cette
affaire
le hesbollah
prévenu se juge
en fait c'était l'ami de michel aoun
premier ministre mikati donc
si le juge je n'ai pas destitué si cet
enquêteur n'est pas destitué le ballon
on va être tombée est-ce que vous
soutenez cette position vu que le pays
est au bord d'une guerre civile
dit que
cent mille personnes cent mille soldats
sont déjà prêts
à participer aux combats donc une guerre
peut commencer
telle ou telle manière c'est lié à la
situation en syrie
s'il vous plaît gardez votre micro et
s'il vous plaît explique henno s'il vous
plaît de quelle guerre par les veaux
du début de quelle guerre
parce que la personne armée sont sortis
dans les rues pour vous rappeler la
guerre civile où les bons
voilà ce n'est pas en ce groupe armé
j'en ai dis pas que c'est le seul groupe
il ya beaucoup de groupes armés qui
agissent en dans le pays aujourd'hui
le juge ne veut pas être destitué
il veut que
consent le gère dans ce processus de la
répartition des pouvoirs cela entraîne
une confrontation dans les rues cela
entraîne une possibilité du début de la
guerre civile
je ne devront pas oublier cette
opportunité cette possibilité de prendre
en compte peut-être que la russie à
l'enterrer à régler ce problème parce
que cela concerne également le problème
syrien
compte tenu des valeurs dont vous avez
parlé aujourd'hui
la première chose concernant l'explosion
dans le port de beyrouth
franchement
quand j'ai appris cette tragédie
j'étais choqué mes condoléances au
peuple libanais grand préjudice je l' ai
appris de la part des journalistes
et
il y avait des produits explosifs qui
ont été déchargé dans le port qui était
hors de contrôle les autorités n'étaient
pas
préoccupés par
ces produits ils pourraient ils
voulaient peut-être peut-être votre
soeur s'est produit et cela est entré en
contradiction avec
les possibilités des acheteurs
je crois que la tragédie est lié à ses
contradictions aussi nous pouvons vous
aider dans l'investigation je ne
comprends pas très bien
de quelle façon les images par satellite
pourrait vous aider mais je vous promets
je vais me renseigner si nous sommes en
possession de ces images et qui vont
aider les investigations on va le faire
hein mais je vais parler à mes collègues
qui sont à disposition de cette
information concernant le hesbollah
l'iran la situation au liban
le hesbollah s'il ya toute sorte
d'attitude envers ce mouvement dans
différents pays ce mouvement de
hizbollah c'est une grande force
politique au liban mais toujours nous
nous prononçons
et quand il s'agit du liban par exemple
pour la résolution de tout conflit par
la voie de dialogue de toutes façons
nous essayons toujours de le faire à nos
sommes en contact avec toutes les forces
politiques au liban et on va
le faire pour le règlement sans
l'effusion de sang bien sûr personne
n'était intéressé
la situation au proche orient est
toujours explosive presque toujours et
bien sûr on va faire le maximum pour
convaincre toutes les parties politiques
de cette processus politique pour dire
qu'il faut rester toujours sur la
plateforme du bon sens s'il vous plaît
prenez votre micro
soutenait
la dic soit le juge
soit
versé
et côté chère madame ne pouvons pas
donner des cons commentaire à propos des
procédures intérieur est ce que nous
soutenons l'ultimatum au pas qu'est ce
que nous soutenons la position de notre
parti cela signifierait
que nos attentes nous sommes du côté
d'une partie d'une partie politique
c'est cela est contre productive
quand il s'agit de nos efforts de
réconciliation donc je mets de réserve
et je ne donne pas des commentaires pour
nous l'essentiel de trouver la plate
forme d'entente
sans
faire recours aux armes c'est l'intérêt
de la russie
je vous en prie
l'université d'état de saint-pétersbourg
monsieur poutine ma question porte sur
l'énergie
no 13 octobre cette année
josep borrell le chef de la diplomatie
européenne
d'abord rendus publics et puis envoyées
vers la commission européenne une
stratégie artix et le nouveau document
de l'union européenne qui passe en revue
beaucoup de problèmes y compris les
questions énergétiques
je vais me concentrer sur deux points
sur sa stratégie d'accord le conseil
l'europe considère que les ressources
par qui se trouvent en afrique le
pétrole le gaz et le charbon doivent
rester dans cette région
peut-être que
pour cela il faut créer
un moratoire imposé un moratoire
temporaire le deuxième point jet li hao
premier
européenne envisage d'élaborer les
outils et financiers et autres pour
faire les états qui comme la fédération
réussi neuf mètres peuvent ex avant dhr
les ressources énergétiques dont ils
vont faire en sorte qu'il ne puisse pas
exploiter les ressources qui ont été
extraits d'un article ma question est
quelle est la vision de la russie persie
mais franchement
je suis tout ce qui se passe dans la
cuisine européenne mais parfois je ne
comprends pas tout
ce qui se passe chaque jour 1
concernant la stratégie haptique de
l'union européenne et la russie possède
sa propre stratégie de notre présence en
arctique
deuxième chose nous avons travaillé
toujours de façon productive dans le
côté actif où sont présents aussi les
pays de l'union européenne et troisième
chose
nous avons parlé toujours d'ailleurs
j'en ai parlé à genève
avec le président byden et son équipe
nous sommes disposés à coopérer dans un
sens large avec toutes les parties
intéressées
dans la région arctique
sur la base
des normes du droit international il ya
plusieurs conventions internationales
la mer territoriale
qui règle il régit la mer territoriale
le droit maritime
de
alors nous procédons à la base de ces
instruments internationaux qu'ils sont
universellement reconnus et nous sommes
prêtes à coopérer sur la base de ces
outils avec toutes les parties
intéressées y compris l'union européenne
si quelqu'un
pourrait
limiter notre droit souverain de
disposer de notre propre territoire
notre mère territoire c'est la partie de
notre territoire
c'est ce sont des moyens illicites cela
concerne également
la zone de 400 milles nautiques a appelé
zone
économique exclusive il ya le droit
international et nous respectons ces
normes internationales nous avons parlé
avec vous tout à l'heure
du north stream 2 donc en conformité de
ces règles
nous devrions obtenir l'autorisation
de la finlande de la suède du danemark
quand nous avons traversé même pas leur
mère territoriales mais
cette zone économique exclusive de ces
états conformément au droit
international nous respectons ce droit
international et les pays européens ont
exigé de la russie de respecter ces
normes internationales mais est ce
qu'ils ne sont pas disposées de
respecter ces normes
on
n'accepte pas
si il est vous très limité notre
activité énergétique c'est leur droit
qu'ils essayaient
nous voyons tout ce qui se passe sur
le marché
européen énergétique s'ils vont procéder
de cette façon de façon arbitraire en se
basant sur je ne sais pas qui je ne sais
pas quoi il y aura des résultats
mauvaise nous avons un conte de fées
elle est reçue le connaisse
où il ya un personnage
qui force un lot
en hiver pêcher avec sa queue et il dit
votre tas que va geler si les européens
adoptent cette voie comme ses
personnages de contes de fées russe ils
vont obtenir ce résultat
c'est pas compliqué de comprendre
c'est la russie le lot c'est celui qui a
plongé sa queue dans l'eau gelée et qui
essayent de pêcher dans des eaux
troubles ils vont être gelés ces
personnages là
il limite des investissements maintenant
la période d'investissement dans le
domaine peut être pétrolier 15 20 30 ans
et déjà les banques refusent
d'accorder des crédits pour réaliser ces
investissements
voilà l'exemple
il y aura
le défi si la pénurie parce que vous
savez
les décisions dans le secteur
énergétique sont adoptées conformément
au cycle politique que j'ai évoqué non
pas par des spécialistes
un collègue l'a dit ce ne sont pas des
ingénieurs des techniciens
mais des hommes politiques qui ne
comprennent pas beaucoup de choses là
dessus et qui trompent leurs électeurs
tout le monde a peur de la zone
climatique
qui nous dessine
des perspectives terrible si on
n'obtient pas la réduction
des émissions la hausse des températures
jusqu'au niveau de la période d'avant
industriel lui
1,5 2
degrés de hausse et c'est terrible on le
sait mais on doit le faire à base de
l'analyse et des experts et nos pas à
base des slogans politiques qui ne sont
pas réalisables
personne ne nous interdit de travailler
sur notre propre
territoire nous sommes disposés à
coopérer avec tout le monde mais à base
professionnelle
monsieur poutine
ce droit surgit comme un rapport de
force comme en équilibre de force peut
être qu'il est temps d'apporter des
modifications il est toujours
fait toujours l'objet de corps de
corrections parfois avec retard mais il
ya une discussion un international il ya
les relations entre les pays qui se
développent plus vite que les normes de
droit ça s'éteint c'est une théorie du
droit qui est connu les relations se
développent plus vite elles ont besoin
d'une régulation juridique et ceux qui
s'occupent de cet aspect juridique en
général le justement deux sont en retard
mais le droit international avec
l'ensemble des normes internationales se
sont pas des règles qu'on inscrit comme
ça dans l'espoir que tout le monde va
les va les respecter mais ce sont des
discussions qui sont faites entre les
pays entre ceux qui régule les relations
entre les pays donc c'est le résultat d'
accords qui ont été conclus signé et
quittons la la réalisation doit se faire
mais s'il s'agit de la souveraineté
on peut pas exiger de quelqu'un que
le pays ne respectent pas
des obligations sans respect de sa
souveraineté donc plus en plus tôt on
renoncera à cette pratique d'imposer la
volonté mieux ce sera
le centre
des états unis
conférence
christian je vous en prie
merci beaucoup
donné la parole je remercie
l'organisation de cette conférence
importante monsieur le président que
j'apprécie beaucoup vos commentaires
important je pense que au cas au leader
mondial n'a jamais parlé de la culture
de son importance
peut-être qu aux etats unis le précédent
au sein de la troupe aurait soutenu ma
parole
mais il parlait de façon aussi mes
lèvres vous savez ma question porte sur
le fait qu' il ya beaucoup de 10 dès que
le président trempe de briguer un
nouveau mandat vous avez parlé dans gala
merkel que pensez-vous de la 12e
présidence et vous vous auriez vous voté
pour lui
rien de drôle
non mais et des noms vous voteriez pour
d'un train comme prochain président
candidat à la prochaine présidence des
états unis
ah oui désolé je n'ai pas compris que
c'étaient les questions adressez à moi
oui j'ai travaillé à l'administration de
30 j'ai travaillé au département ou de
l'état au début de la présidence de 30
je pense qu'il a changées la notion d'un
conservatisme
sa position était plutôt aligné à la
vôtre qu'on vous avait parlé du
conservatisme 100 mais je pense que dans
notre système si vous brillez le
deuxième mandat
que vous êtes pour la deuxième fois au
pouvoir sait déjà qu'on est comme un
canard boiteux brad
est en fait d'un côté l'administration
de trompes
disons le elle n'était pas toujours
efficace il y a eu des responsables de
haut rang qui n'étaient pas d'accord
avec la politique de trompe on pensait
que la pouvoirs du président ne sortait
pas des limites de la maison blanche
bien sûr je voudrais que les
conservateurs comme un mâle de synthèse
le gouverneur de la floride en floride
participent mais s'il y avait le choix
entre trois chercheurs les
cercles avait permettez moi de ne pas
donner mon point de vue est de ne pas
commenter je vous ai dit sinon vous avez
inscrit comme agent de l'étranger
mais l'idée elle-même que vous venez de
forme réel mais compréhensible
merci pour votre participation
merci monsieur poutine vous savez évoqué
la pénurie d'eau les problèmes
alimentaires ce sont des défis actuels
étaient à votre avis quel rôle
constructif la russie en tant qu'
une puissance qui a beaucoup de
ressources d'eau potable qui a un gros
on décolle de région de recherche
content qu'un grand exportateur
produits alimentaires qu'est ce que je
pourrais faire dans ce domaine pas
uniquement en russie
c'est ce que nous faisons déjà et nous
allons développer cette activité je vais
vous expliquer de quoi il s'agit ici il
s'agit d'une préoccupation
les à l'approvisionnement alimentaire
j'ai déjà dit que je n'ai pas les
récemment avec le gouvernement
aujourd'hui s'il y a des ruptures dans
l'économie internationale
avec l'augmentation des pénuries
l'inflation comme résultat
de la chaîne d'approvisionnement
pas seulement dans le
pas seulement au niveau local mais au
niveau même pas besoin de transporter je
sais pas en angleterre mais on sait par
exemple que et un rôle important qui a
été jouée par le cos vie de 19 mais il
ya d'autres raisons aussi et tout cela
pris ensemble fait que
regarder on a parlé
de l'augmentation
des prix pour les ressources
énergétiques
ce qui entraîne aussi une augmentation
du prix de l'électricité chez nous c'est
20 euros le kilomètre dans les pays
européens c'est 300
donc le niveau de revenus est différent
m'enfin là la défiance est quand même
beaucoup trop forte
et donc que font certains
gouvernements certains
représentants d'organisations
internationales disent mais très bien
mais ils disent qu'il faut accorder des
subsides aux citoyens
pour
soutenir cette augmentation des tarifs à
l'électricité effectivement il faut que
l'état apporte son aide aux citoyens
mais si une décision
dans l'eure parce que ensuite les autres
citoyens ils vont souffrir
parce que le volume initial de la
ressource énergétique n'a pas été
augmenté donc certains quelqu'un donc
c'est à dire que les les citoyens qui
vont bénéficier de subventions ils ne
vont pas être
ne vont pas augmenter le volume donc le
volume de production ne va pas augmenter
lui donc ça veut dire que
il y aura une réduction de consommation
et notamment dans l'industrie
avec comme réaction en chaîne une
augmentation des neuf et toute cette
chaîne elle est longue ça concerne le
métal les les automobiles
les pince à cravate et c'est enfin je
veux dire ça concerne toutes les
entreprises qui produisent par exemple
des engrais
et
qui sont à base de gaz naturel dont il
ya déjà des fermetures du donc il y aura
un manque
d'investissements au niveau de son gré
pour le temps pour le travail des sols
et donc la produc la production
de biens alimentaires et donc on
retourne c'est toujours on revient aux
problèmes des citoyens qu'on veut aider
et donc la situation n'est pas bonne
donc il faut penser à autre chose faut
penser est-ce qu'il faut
mettre des restrictions sur la
production notamment dans l'arctique
faut-il pour des motifs politiques
limiter certains itinéraires
énergétique notamment north stream ii
faut penser à des choses élémentaires
ici
avec l'augmentation des risques et se
concentrer sur les spots ou bien
en partant d'un d'une réflexion de bon
sens à long terme sur les
investissements à long terme s'appuyer
sur au moins des contrats à long terme
voilà à quoi il faut réfléchir et à ce
moment là on pourra éviter des crises
brutale
aujourd'hui la russie a pensé à
contribution importante dans la sécurité
alimentaire puisque nous augmentation
de fournitures sur le marché mondial
avec
25 milliards de dollars d'exportations
en bien agroalimentaire c'est très
important et je tiens à remercier
justement les acteurs du secteur
agroalimentaire c'est leur mérite c'est
leur travail
c'est plus que ce qu'on aurait pu
qu'on ait pu rêver merci aux européens
pour les sanctions dans le domaine de
l'agriculture donc nous avons mis vous
en prie des contre mesures après les
mesures de rétorsion après ces sanctions
voilà notamment avec le principe du de
la substitution des informe des
importations donc là effectivement je
sais pas qui a pas de préoccupation
enfin l'effet global est positif donc il
ya eu beaucoup de nouvelles conceptions
qui ont été faits notamment dans le
domaine dans les secteurs de haute
technologie et j'espère que nous allons
poursuivre la production agricole
c'est-à-dire qu'on a on a un changement
climatique qui en train des changements
dans l'agriculture ce que je veux dire
c'est que par exemple
la qualité des sols dans le tchernoziom
par exemple change il ya un mouvement
vers le nord
donc il ya des cataclysmes naturels qui
se font
désertification enfin la russie
régis et elle se satisfera elle même
mais aussi les autres partenaires sur le
marché international à des prix mondiaux
acceptable d'autre part j'ai dit que des
entreprises fermaient des entreprises de
production d'engrais ferme et dont
dépend donc eu la qualité les quantités
d
récolte mais nous justement nous
fournissons les volumes nécessaires en
engrais et nous continuerons à le faire
d'ailleurs nos engrais en qualité sont
parmi les meilleurs au monde
donc
les entreprises compétitives ne cherchez
pas trop de parler de chercher à ne pas
trop parler de ça pour éviter les
impacts négatifs sur la santé mais
aujourd'hui maintenant toulon n'a pas
l'aura dans dans les médias mais
aujourd'hui il ya cette évolution des
prix sur
les
sur le pétrole ya ces histoires de
retournement de des flux
des rivières n'est pas récent mais la
russie fait partie des pays
dont l'équilibré
hydrique et
stable pour
une période longue mais devant réfléchir
à la propreté de nos rivières à la
gestion des eaux
dans le baïkal par exemple on a
suffisamment de problèmes je vais pas
entrer dans les détails
de nouveaux problèmes sont apparus mais
nous allons travailler continuer à
travailler dans le cadre des plans que
nous nous sommes fixés et mais nous
allons tâcher de surmonter l'ensemble
des difficultés que ce constat
question
poursuivre les discussions
beaucoup de travail pour renforcer la
force
la force ou de la russie on a effectué
les échanges culturels
tous les objectifs ne sont pas atteints
par exemple en ce qui concerne l'image
de la russie à l'étranger en ce qui
concerne
le dialogue avec
participants étrangers ma question
comment faire en sorte pour que la force
molle de l'abc soit vraiment efficace se
respecter soi-même ça c'est le principal
faut pas sortir de ce même pour chercher
à montrer qu'on est très bon non ce ne
faut pas le faire
c'est le principal donc avoir du respect
pour soi pour son histoire pour sa
culture et à ce moment là les gens
seront attirés
merci
professeur
au début de votre intervention vous avez
mentionné le problème des changements
climatiques liés aux incendies aux
inondations n'ont pas uniquement russie
mais dans des pays différents c'est en
octobre
il y aura un logis la conférence la
compo avant le 6
glasgow
la conférence de partie comment est-ce
que vos visions sur le changement
climatique ont changé parce que nous
avons parlé des changements climatiques
pendant la session du club de valdaï
mais la situation s'est dégradée avec le
temps est-ce que la russie peut devenir
un leader dans le cadre de ces
discussions portant sur les changements
climatiques pendant la conférence des
parties cette question a été posée
pendant leur semaine énergétiques de
russie la semaine dernière vous avez
annoncé que vers l'année 2060 vous
voulez assurer la neutralité carbone de
la russie alors est-ce que la russie est
prête à devenir un leader dans cette
question
en outre
beaucoup de pays y compris les états
unis et nos pays européens on parlait du
cap vert
cette question
peut devenir uniquement en question
technique mais une question des
changements de la qualité de vie des
gens
comment rendre leur vie plus stable
y compris s'appuyant sur l'expérience de
la pandémie c'est à dire
comment attendre cet équilibre entre la
vie de la société le fonctionnement de
l'état
vous avez parlé de la possibilité du
leadership russe dans ce domaine mais il
me semble
qu'il faut
partir des réalités
oui d'ici 2060
nous voulons obtenir la neutralité
carbone oui nous le faisons
à maintes reprises j'en ai parlé et je
le répète notre équilibre énergétique et
plus vert par rapport à d'autres de
notre pays nous avons 86 % de notre
équilibre énergétique qui est composé du
nucléaire qui n'émet pas
là
l'electra l'électricité hydraulique et
aussi les ressources alternatives ton
disque aux états unis
77 en allemagne 64 dans les pays
asiatiques
encore moins est ce que il ne s'agit pas
du leadership c'est la réalité bien sûr
nous comprenons que ce n'est pas
suffisant pour nous parce que il y à la
hausse de la température en russie
qui est plus rapide
que partout dans le monde surtout en
sibérie dans le grand nord et cela
implique des grands des conséquences
pour notre territoire qui se trouve un
kick it qui se trouve dans le grand nord
et cela concerne la qualité de vie
par exemple liquider les décharges
publiques dans des grandes
agglomérations qui polluent
l'environnement nous y travaillons
sans parler des situations dans des
grands centres industriels il ya tout un
programme
de transformation on voudrait être plus
rapide mais nous assumons notre
responsabilité
la crise de 2008 2009 nous a empêchés
qui a été importé en russie et mais à
l'époque l'industrie laissé je sais les
russes
disait que beaucoup d'entreprises
risquaient d'être fermés si on réaliser
tous ces projets écologiques mais de
toute façon aujourd'hui toutes les
décisions législatives sont réalisés
nous avons douze grandes agglomérations
qui est m
le plus de co2 faut partir de ce
programme et ensuite on va passer dans
tous les secteurs de l'économie cela
autres dans le cadre de nos projets
nationaux qui est notre priorité
ici on parle de la neutralité carbone
il faut dire que 45 1% parmi et toutes
les émissions sont absorbés
d'ailleurs dans ce sens nos insistant
sur le fait qu'il faut prendre en compte
nos possibilités d'absorption nos forêts
nos mères tous les territoires et qui
sont liées à l'océan
c'est une pelle et objective il faut en
prendre en compte en part ça nous avons
aussi et d'écrans de réserves
qui sont liées à la réalisation des
projets dans le secteur des services
communaux et l'efficacité énergétique
et là dessus
nous avons du pain sur la planche mais
en général
nous avons besoin non seulement de
réaliser de façon mécanique
des mesures qui ont été prévues mais
nous avons besoin de résultats
et nous avons l'intention en toute
transparence d'y travailler
mais je ne voudrais pas que cette lutte
pour la préservation de la nature
du climat se transforme en outil de
concurrencer sur les marchés mondiaux ça
c'est mauvais
qui va saper la confiance de tout ce que
nous faisons pour l'avenir de l'humanité
européenne va en produire la taxe
carbone
pour le moment nous n'avons pas de
décision qui sapent nos intérêts qui ne
sont pas transparentes ne sont pas
prises
j'ai parlé à certains dirigeants je ne
vais pas énumérer les nommer ils
comprennent que
les certaines positions qui sont
formulées au niveau des institutions
européennes ne sont pas transparentes ne
sont pas justes et tout cela
exige des corrections nos espérant à un
dialogue avec d'autres pays
notre
dieu conseil des recherches ce qu'on
peut allumer la visioconférence je vous
en prie
je vous en prie posez votre question
oui merci beaucoup
je vous demande pardon oui je me suis
connecté un format virtuel monsieur le
président je voudrais parler tu
travailles des états unis et de la
russie
sur la question de l'afghanistan et
l'iran temps où la russie et les etats
unis et hong kong béret
avant encore
qaïda pour que natal et bon quitte le
pays perdre leur pouvoir à votre avis la
coopération antiterroriste entre la
russie et les etats unis est possible
souhaitable
peut-être que nous avons des objectifs
communs dans le domaine comme il ya
longtemps
je pense que la coopération
antiterroriste
de la russie et des états unis non
seulement possible et souhaitable il est
né et les nécessaires 1
à maintes reprises et nous en avons
parlé
malheureusement vous n'êtes pas là dans
cette salle 1 mais il est évident que
c'est une menace commune qui
elle ne devient pas
moins importante par rapport à kid il ya
20 ans nous avons l'élargissement de ce
danger qui porte
un caractère global est et ce n'est
qu'en unissant nos efforts qu'on peut
lutter contre cette menace j'en ai parlé
déjà
nos services de sécurité sont en contact
mais à mon avis on pourrait travailler
de façon plus étroite mais nous sommes
reconnaissants à nos partenaires
américains pour les informations qui
nous ont permis de prévenir
les attentats sur le territoire russe je
vous assure que nous ferons tout notre
possible pour transmettre les
informations à nos collègues américains
le cac et chaque ici cela représente
l'intérêt et si cette information sera
en notre disposition c'est notre intérêt
commun
étaient les bons pour pouvoir de facto
arrive participer
nos différences si à moscou est ce que
pendant longtemps on va les qualifier de
l'organisation terroriste il ne s'agit
pas de nous de la russie quand vous le
voyant comme vous voyez nous coopérons
avec les représentants des talibans ils
ont évité à moscou nous sommes en
contact sur le territoire afghan et ses
décisions sont adoptées au niveau des
nations unies et nous attendons de la
part du talibans qui contrôlent la
situation dans ce pays en afghanistan
nous attendons que la situation se
développe de façon positive et en
fonction de l'évolution nous allons
prendre des décisions sur l'exclusion du
talent est bondée liste des
organisations terroristes je crois que
nous nous rapprochons de cette décision
en tout cas c'est notre volonté mais ces
décisions doivent être adoptées de la
même façon
quand nous avons inclus et le taliban
dans cette liste
aujourd'hui il ya eu peu de questions de
la part de l'asie
un contact avec nos professeurs du japon
s'il thomas nous pouvons entamer une
visioconférence merci
sur le précédent pour moi c'est un grand
honneur
pas pu être présent ici à sotchi mais
votre rapport à être très intéressant y
compris votre idée que s'il ya lieu d
anachronisme
aujourd'hui peut-être d'un acronis mhz
de plus aux graves
il sait ce qu'on voit à l'asie
avec le ministre monsieur abel vous avez
essayé de combler cette lacune
dans les recherches
en quête de l'accord de la paix
mais les ministres japonais ils se sont
succédé sans rencontrer
à votre invité sera le futur des
relations bilatérales
quels seront les perspectives en ce qui
concerne l'accord de la peindre au japon
ou la russie merci mais en effet
la vie politique au japon
prévoit les modifications sur l'arène
politique
qui sont assez rapide mais les intérêts
des peuples russe et japonais sont
intangibles qui sont basés sur la
volonté de
régler
nos relations et la conclusion de ce
traité de paix c'est notre volonté
également malgré le fait
qu'il y a
ce changement d de la situation
politique au japon j'ai parlé avec le
nouveau premier ministre du japon
c'est une personne qui a expérimenté qui
était chargé des relations
internationales
politiquement il est très proche au
premier ministre à b et dans ce sens je
pense
qu'on va
constater cette continuité de la
politique japonaise vis-à-vis de la
russie avec le premier ministre ab nous
avons
mise en place
d'écrans des bases de notre travail
conjoint pour élever le niveau de nos
relations à
un niveau nouveau j'espère que ça va
continuer
en question
depuis deux heures déjà j'ai une
proposition
optimiser leurs processus de travail
nous allons
vite des questions très brève la
déclaration comme c'était de la part de
madame thériault mais des questions
vraiment très brave
répondre
oui
alors je vais essayer
trench-coat
réprimant pas commence comme une
mitrailleuse
wilson sur la pandémie
je confie
mon agent on devait trancher
aujourd'hui la plus grande dans le plus
grand danger c'est la pandémie qui
persistent
j'ai entendu que le niveau de la
vaccination en russie est très faible
quel est votre avis de la vaccination
obligatoire
j'en ai déjà parlé
la vaccination est obligatoire s'il fait
partie d'un calendrier national
mais la vaccination
ils contrôlent qu un virus n'a pas été
inscrite au calendrier national et donc
elle n'est pas obligatoire
conformément à la loi en vigueur les
autorités régionales ont
le droit de mettre en place une
vaccination obligatoire
en lien avec une augmentation de
l'épidémie sur recommandation des
autorités sanitaires
pour certaines catégories
professionnelles
ce net c'est ce qui se fait dans la
pratique mais je suis pas partisan d'une
vaccination
obligatoire parce que
de toute façon il y aura des façons
d'éviter cette vaccination obligatoire
il y aura des faux certificats
peut-être au contraire que ceux qui
par exemple ont un vaccin occidental
j'ai déjà vu cette évolution de la
situation par exemple un citoyen
européen se fait vacciner
ici au spoutnik
et là bas ils achètent un certificat
disant qu'il a été vaccinée en fait
et c'est les médecins des médecins
européens qu'ils nous le disent
donc ils considèrent que le spoutnik et
plus efficaces et plus sûrs mais la
question c'est pas ça je dis pas ça pour
faire une propagande pour ce pique nique
je dis simplement que toute imposition
d'une des fines décision est
relativement facilement contournée
des centaines de milliers de personnes
qui songent à à rédiger une loi et il ya
des millions de personnes qui songent à
la contourne est donc s'est pas imposé
mais
prouver et convaincre qu'il vaut mieux
être rationné que d'être malade j'en ai
parlé tout récemment encore ça ne
concerne pas seulement la russie ça
concerne aussi d'autres pays
y a que deux schéma d'évolution soit
avoir été malade soit être vaccinées est
passé entre les gouttes c'est pas
possible
et donc pour augmenter
la confiance des citoyens envers
l'action de l'état il faut prouver
donner des exemples convaincre et
j'espère que ça va marcher chez nous
mais si au sein du japon
merci monsieur le précédent ma question
concerne l'afghanistan
nous avons vu la défaite des etats-unis
de retrait de l'afghanistan
la stratégie sur le plan stratégique en
général est ce que cela va changer la
position des états unis et comment
comment est-ce que cela va impacter
l'ordre mondial dont vous avez parlé
la première chose que je voudrais dire
c'est que le président des états unis a
bien agi il a bien fait de procéder au
retrait des forces en afghanistan
et il comprenait probablement peut-être
qu'il connaissait pas dans les détails
commencé à les spéciales mais comprenez
que de toute façon la situation
interne
mènerait à ça et donc il a pris la
responsabilité de le faire sur la façon
dont ça s'est déroulé nous avons vu oui
on aurait pu faire ça autrement et bien
évidemment d'une façon ou d'une autre
cela
va affecter
les pays qui
regardent les etats-unis qui considèrent
les états unis comme un allié et je
pense que maintenant va
certain laps de temps va passer des
choses vont se stabiliser
évidemment à un
horizon proche évidemment il va y avoir
des conséquences mais
je pense que
l'attrait des pays ne dépend pas de ça
il ya une puissance économique et
militaire qui est plus importante
depuis 100 ans
de dialogue
vous savez alexandre ça dépend pas
seulement de nous si la partie allemande
manifestent un intérêt pour cela nous
activerons c'était ce travail il existe
toujours ce dialogue de saint
pétersbourg il continue bien sûr on peut
renforcer les liens entre les deux pays
on est les rendre plus intensif et plus
efficace à je comprends mais il faut
dépolitiser tout ça et
encourager ces échanges mais la
coalition
la formation de la coalition semble
assez complexe en allemagne contenu d
opinions politiques des différentes
forces politiques qui peuvent entrer
dans cette éventuelle coalition on verra
pour l'instant je sais pas ce que c'est
mais évidemment nous sommes pour ce
dialogue
anatolie
si la chine à d'autres pays passe à des
voitures électriques c'est une partie
importante de leur transition
vous savez j'en ai souvent parlé déjà
mais bien sûr quand
les automobiles se déplace dans une
ville basse et justement une des causes
principales en plus avec l'activité des
citoyens le
l'activité humaine l'activité
industrielle tout cela c'est une source
de pollution mes lectrices et elle vient
d'où
donc faut pas se tromper ici les les
voitures automobiles électriques c'est
bien mais la pollution atmosphérique de
la production d'électricité
c'est peut-être pas très bien mais la
génération
carbure par exemple on vient à l'essence
vient justement de parler de l'allemagne
mais là cette génération carbone elle
est deux fois plus grande qu'en russie
donc trente 30 % 32 % peut-être est chez
nous c'est 15 16%
mais évidemment c'est bien en principe
mais pour un pays comme la russie
avec des
réserves globales de gaz qui sont
énormes ou évidemment on peut faire par
exemple des véhicules
avec et de moteurs gaza c'est possible
mais on va changer les équilibres
carbone ici
oui je me suis déplacé à galets au vin
oui je me déplace sur ses véhicules et
non jeu pratiquement pas senti de
différence non
mais c'est pas la question
mais c'est pas inutile de le dire
ce qui concerne l'histoire et la mémoire
rencontre on a beaucoup parlé
ou
soviétique
[Musique]
fêtait l'anniversaire de 800 temps
d'alexandre qui vous avez une personne
en vue du monument ce qui a impressionné
beaucoup de personnes mais pour quelques
raisons
tout ce qui est lié aux 300 temps de la
pire est passé sous silence peut être
nous avons honte de ses paroles c'est
dommage parce que c'était une grande
partie de notre histoire
l'histoire à partir de jusqu'à la
fédération de russie quel que soit
nous avons envoyé une lettre
que vous allez chez sur sa fenêtre
même s'ils ne participent pas
directement on va se souvenir de cet
événement je suis d'accord avec vous la
continuité dans l'histoire c'est un plus
importante pour comprendre où on va
je suis d'accord avec vous ici nous
manquons une étape si je présente mes
mes excuses mais la prochaine fois
le prochain événement sera lié à votre
nom
j'ai une question
la russie
vous savez je réfléchis pas à mon rôle
dans l'espace dès qu'on commence à
réfléchir à ça ça veut dire qu'il faut
arrêter de travailler
ça commence à gêner
dans la prise de décision je vous le dis
tout à fait franchement c'est que je
commence à réfléchir à ce que je
commence à être perçue comment ça va
faire qu'est-ce qu'on veut dire les
livres je vois la
donne un coup dans le mur et on arrête
de travailler donc
en ce qui concerne de ce que j'ai réussi
on avait 40 millions en deçà du seuil de
pauvreté aujourd'hui on est à 10,9
millions mais c'est quand même pas 40
c'est peut-être le résultat principal
on à l'économie qui a été remis sur pied
certains secteurs industriels notamment
l'industrie de défense avaient quasiment
cessé d'exister
encore un
encore un peu de temps et à ce moment là
ç'aurait été complètement
perdu tant au niveau de la production
qu'au niveau de la recherche au on a
complètement remis sur pied cette
activité et je pense que dans chaque
entité de la fédération
il y avait des
législations et des
charte qui était complètement délirante
avec le le droit de créer sa propre
monnaie de créer ses propres frontières
mais c'était ils oubliaient d'inscrire
que c'était une entité de la fédération
on a surmonté tous la lutte contre le
terrorisme international
vous savez je vais vous dire
ce à quoi je pense parfois et je vous le
dis en toute franchise oui nous avons
surmonté ces étapes difficiles
notamment par exemple la lutte contre le
terrorisme
c'est pas c'est loin d'être seulement dû
à mes efforts mais bien plutôt à ceux du
peuple aux et je dis ça sans
sans apparat je le dis simplement parce
que j'ai vu les épreuves les souffrances
qu'ont connu les familles russes et la
russie a su
passer cette étape et et cette passion
qui est apte à chaud au coeur russe dans
la passion dans le peuple russe ce
stimulus de stimulation cette motivation
interne on là elle est très forte
on cherche
exception
ce sujet
moi personnellement je n'ai pas trouvé
cette image du futur parce que le monde
n'est pas du tout clair peut-être que
j'adore
est-ce que vous avez cette vision du
futur de la russie ou du monde que vous
voudriez voir
que les générations futures
[Musique]
vous savez on peut dire beaucoup de
choses à ce sujet
et d'une façon ou d'une autre c'est déjà
répondu plus ou moins à cette question
je dois parvenir aux formulations que
que j'avais déjà utilisé mais je
partirai simplement
[Musique]
de l'idée principale de notre discussion
d'aujourd'hui c'est quoi déjà
non non le thème d'aujourd'hui
pas seulement
voilà
donc il faudrait s'en souvenir donc
c'est le principal c'est l'essentiel
j'ai évoqué perdre et f
on sait qui il a il ya plusieurs
ouvrages importants de lui qui sont
connues
et qui
est qu'il avait parlé de la liberté
notamment à propos du moyen âge mais il
avait parlé surtout au centre du
développement doit être doigts l'homme
doit figurer l'homme est plus important
que la société et que l'état
donc je voudrais que à l'avenir
toutes les ressources de la société de
l'état soient concentrés sur les
intérêts de l'homme et c'est l'objectif
que nous devons nous fixer et nous
devons être efficace dans la mise en
place d'un tel système c'est difficile
mais en tout cas il faut tendre à cela
allez on va faire ces trois blocs 1 2 3
blocs
voilà lever la main là bas je nomme
alesi
tradixionales
elle
auparavant cette contradiction
déclencher des guerres mondiales pour
l'instant nous ne voyons pas de guerre
mondiale ont moins chaudes vous avez une
note agit
justement c'est ma question peut-être
que nous la voyons pas parce qu'il ya
des armes nucléaires dans le show est ce
que cela veut dire que cela ne peut pas
survenir impossible ici si cela ne peut
pas être déclenchées alors c'est comme
chez dostoïevski s'il n'ya pas de dieu
tout est possible s'il n'y a pas de
menace d'une guerre mondiale c'est une
irresponsabilité totale on peut faire
n'importe quoi parce qu'il n'y aura pas
de guerre mondiale donc quel obstacle
pour une politique active etc
si une menace de la guerre mondiale si
le danger d'une guerre mondiale existe
est-ce que la russie en tant que sur
puissance nucléaire en tant que pays qui
a survécu des guerres vraiment très dur
on vous avait parlé qui crée la paix
être la paix c'est aussi l'une des
valeurs de l'humanité est ce que la
russie doit être plus actives en disant
que la protection de la paix la défense
de la paix c'est l'objectif de la
politique étrangère de la russie et
faire quelque chose dans la pratique
vous savez nos parlant beaucoup
des choses positives
très importante
mais nos partenaires
préfèrent de ne pas apercevoir certaines
choses mais il faut persister
tout ce que nous disons c'est pas un
travail facile on va continuer notre
travail vous avez parlé de l'armé
nucléaire
lui c'est une grande responsabilité et
une puissance nucléaire et vous avez
également dit que dans ces conditions
la troisième guerre mondiale
n'est pas possible
il existe la menace de la destruction
totale de tous les états ne l'oublions
pas s'il vous plaît
le secteur central je vous en prie
tatyana kotova
la situation urge des relations
internationales de la france une
question qui préoccupe la france ces
derniers jours les journaux publient
les articles concernant la présence des
mercenaires russes au mali ma question
pour être bref est ce que les intérêts
d'une société militaire privée nous ce
qui
nous avons discuté de cette question
avec nos collègues français
le président macron à a parlé sur ce
sujet avec moi
vous avez évoqué des sociétés privées et
paramilitaires qui ne sont pas conformes
aux intérêts de l'état russe ils ne sont
pas dirigées par l'état russe c'est ce
sont les affaires privées les intérêts
privés qui sont liées à l'extraction des
sources énergétiques de l'or des pierres
précieuses
mais si cela entre en contradiction
avec les intérêts russes bien sûr nous
devons réagir et nous allons réagir
président
merci
concernées au caucase du sud
[Musique]
mais la question n'est pas tranchée
n'est pas réglé jusqu'à la fin
d'août
dans certains pays
il ya les république fraternelle
pays de la région
on a conçu un format qui a été soutenue
par la russie il s'agit de 3 pouces
crois mais pour l'instant ce n'est pas
opérationnel
et l'azerbaïdjan
la russie
avait un fort mal sur le couloir nord
sud
la russie la turquie avait pour moi
malheureusement
on a vu l'apparition d'un phénomène
terroristes dans le caucase du sud
[Musique]
ici le rôle de la russie est bien sûr
très important
d'autres formats aussi avec la
participation de l'arménie à votre avis
faut-il avoir une initiative pour créer
un format ou à votre avis quel format
qui sera plus efficace pour prendre en
compte des intérêts
des républiques du caucase du sud et des
pays de la région merci
d'abord
je
respecte la sagesse politique du
président azerbaïdjanais et du président
arménien malgré toute la tragédie des
événements il est sont au dessus de
surmonter la conjoncture politique et
prendre des décisions responsables
dans les deux pays il ya des questions
qui se posent il ya toujours des forces
politiques
qui sont mécontentes ou considérer qu'il
qu'on pouvait faire mieux mais il ya
toujours une réponse essayez donc de
faire mieux
de toute façon
le président aliev et le premier
ministre arménien à ont réussi à arrêter
l'effusion de sang
ça c'est le plus important la sauvegarde
des vies humaines mais de toute façon il
y à un autre aspect important
créé des conditions de règlement à long
terme dans la région en général et ces
conditions doivent être créés seulement
à condition que les deux parties
adopter
des décisions dès
qu'ils ont été prises en tant que
décision à long terme et vont apprécier
les priorités de la coexistence
pacifique
c'est dans l'intérêt général
l'azerbaïdjan à l'intérêt pour
pour avoir les liens avec nakhitchevan
et pour dégeler
les communications
c'est un des objectifs qui se posent
devant l'arménie c'est à dire
avoir une vie économique normale dans la
région y compris à avoir des liens avec
le surprenant c'est dans l'intérêt de
l'armée ni dégeler les relations avec la
turquie pour que ces relations soient
modernes
[Musique]
dans les deux cas cela va amener vers
l'obtention d'un grand objectif la
coexistence pacifique des deux stars et
la création des conditions pour la vie
économique
est ce que c'est possible oui bien sûr
c'est possible
et nous avons fait tout ce qui dépend de
nous pour arrêter l'effusion de sang
mais
nos soldats de la paix
remplissent leur mission
le de 50 mille réfugiés sont de retour
chez eux et donc nous avons réussi à
préserver la situation dans le dans la
zone de conflit
c'est à dire qu'
il n'y a pas de conflit armé bien sûr ya
des incidents parfois
il y a des morts mais il est difficile
d'imaginer
une situation délicate après toutes les
années de confrontation mais il est
important de régler la situation à la
frontière et bien sûr on peut pas le
faire sans la participation de la russie
et je crois que nous n'avons plus besoin
de deux personnes
puisque les états majeurs
l'état major général russe et possèdent
des cartes qui témoignent des frontières
qui passait à l'époque soviétique
bien sûr nous avons besoin d'un
compromis mutuelle
aplanir peut être une ligne avoir un
compromis mais à base avantageuse et
c'est possible
mais nous nous prononçons pour le format
multi partie par exemple le groupe de
minsk qui pourrait être dynamisée nous y
travaillons avec nos partenaires mais
l'essentiel l'objectif principal c'est
la création
de la situation de sécurité dans la
région et garantir l'avenir des
relations entre les pays
mais notre objectif nous l'avons atteint
pour le moment et on va voir
qu'est-ce qu'il va passer dans l'avenir
oui
nous avons prévu la prolongation de la
présence militaire russe dans la région
mais l'essentiel c'est de construire les
relations entre les deux pays et
j'espère qu'on va réussir et
égoïste aux mines on va peut-être
terminée puisque on parle déjà depuis
longtemps
organisation
et la perspective de la participation de
la russie
en général si ces organisations
vous travaillez sur la réalisation des
objectifs
qui sont les leurs
les perspectives de l'existence de ces
organismes existent le conseil de
l'europe
c'est l'histoire européenne plutôt
le eux
aussi mais si il est s'occupe
exclusivement de l'espace post
soviétique et donner des leçons à des
états indépendants qui ont été formés
suite à la désagrégation de l'union
soviétique ils n'ont pas de perspective
pour leur existence enfin plus de
perspectives et je vous assure que si la
russie
sort d'une de ces organisations
on va voir qu'est ce qui va se passer
avec ces organisations du point de vue
de la participation d'autres pays vous
savez
personne n'a besoin des leçons
il faut voir d'une manière plus large
des questions de la coopération
humanitaire par exemple
si on parle de du conseil de l'europe ou
bien la sécurité sur l'europe
en général la dernière question
peut-être je vous en prie
oui vous avez la parole
merci beaucoup je représente une à
pakistan islamabad avec tout mon respect
bien sûr je comprends que la campagne
anti terroriste est très importante au
niveau international va se poursuivre
une ma question est la suivante elle
porte sur des négociations qui continue
il s'agit du pakistan d'où l'erreur de
là aussi de la rpc qui la république
populaire de chine bien sûr le pakistan
à contribuer au processus en général
pour l'instant
nous voyons des problèmes car
si l'appel est bon
parviennent à arrêter le trafic des
drogues
parviennent protéger les territoires
entre nos deux contre deux s'ils
parviennent à éliminer cette structure
quelle sera la réaction de la part du
pakistan de la russie et de la chine
c'est
la reconnaissance je ne pense pas à ma
question à propos de la reconnaissance
des talibans mais il est important de
permettre au pas les banques de se
développer économiquement pour le
développement ou du pays il est
nécessaire de régler les problèmes
sociaux il s'agit notamment de
l'éducation de la santé
tout ce qui concerne le domaine social
d'autres facteurs
bien en tant que votre réponse à cette
question
il est important de régler leur problème
qui a été engendrée par l'otan je pense
que la russie la chine doivent présider
ce processus merci
mais pour ceux concernant tous ces
problèmes qui ont été engendrées par
l'otan
je crois que
tout ce qui a été fait par les états
unis ont été
critiqué à maintes reprises mais enfin
je crois que la décision du président by
day était peut-être correct mais après
les retraits des le retrait des troupes
américaines il faut regarder dans
l'avenir mais bien sûr les états unis
devraient assumer leurs responsabilités
puisque ils ont toutes sortes d'outils
pour faire pression
sur le taliban et l'union européenne
également faut pas être
hautain comment
l'union européenne le fait souvent avec
une sorte de snobisme hui ils ont leur
responsabilité pour tout ce qui se passe
en afghanistan il faut aider le peuple
afghan actuellement mais il faut partir
du fait
qu'on peut pas répéter les erreurs du
passé on peut pas imposer au peuple
afghan tout ce que voulait le faire
l'union soviétique les états unis
mais l'union soviétique est d' adopter
une position plutôt pondérer les jours à
vis et comment on les appelait les
soviétiques
c'est comme ça qu'on les appelait en
afghanistan s'était pas trop négatif
mais les pays de la région bien sûr sont
intéressés par le règlement en
afghanistan et la russie va faire tout
notre possible et nous voyons que les
talibans essaient de lutter contre les
groupes radicaux
et qui sont des groupes terroristes
à l'instar de l'état islamique
lui à un moment donné
il est accompagné les actions de
talibans et maintenant ils agressent le
taliban mais à l'intérieur de
l'afghanistan
le taliban devra quand même à construire
des relations avec toutes les ethnies
avec les groupes religieux avec les
organisations les associations également
organisations politiques
commençons par la composante ethnique
oui le taliban c'est plutôt des push to
know
mais il ya aussi des tadjiks
de 40 à 47 % selon les estimations
écoutez c'est beaucoup
il ya des ouzbeks également des cazaril
et si on regarde cette composante
ethnique oui bien sûr
au gouvernement on trouve les
représentants de ces ethnies mais par où
un grand poste
mais les gens voudraient occupé des
postes importants dans la direction du
pays et il faut rechercher cet équilibre
non nos n'imposons rien mais nous disons
tout simplement
quelle est notre vision nous faisons
tout notre possible pour
apaiser les appétits de certains
d'ailleurs nous sommes en contact avec
toutes les forces politiques en
afghanistan et nous construisons des
relations assez stable avec tout le
monde au maire aux voudrait rechercher
des compromis acceptables pour que les
problèmes qui sont posés ne soit pas
réglé à l'aide de deux armes
pour qu'ils correspondent par exemple
les intérêts des femmes puisque
l'afghanistan se dit être un état
moderne et je crois que le rôle et
l'importance du pakistan est aussi fier
important peut-être
autant important que le rôle de la
russie et de la chine et nous sommes
intéressés dans le développement de la
coopération avec votre pays pour obtenir
notre résultat que nous recherchons est
sans aucun doute les intérêts de la
russie et dans le fait que l'afghanistan
finalement soit sorti
de cette guerre civile
interminable et pour que le peuple
de ce pays se sentent
dans le cadre de
ses frontières nationales en sécurité et
les chances pour la propri prospérité et
le développement
on va faire tout notre possible pour
obtenir ce résultat
non non non je ne prétends pas votre
salaire
parce que nous avons parlé presque tous
les sujets merci beaucoup
c'est pendant cette conversation que
nous n'allons pas aller à new york je
sais pas pour l'instant l'année
prochaine le club de valdaï se réunira à
sushis nous espérons vraiment que tout
ça va bien nous allons vous voir un
présentiel nous allons parler pendant
son coeur merci merci à vous
c'est pas nécessaire de tenir la session
plénière à new york mais sans aucune
ironie
et on nous avons l'intérêt d'être à new
york en afghanistan par exemple pourquoi
pas c'est très utile
vous savez cela a du sens dans d'autres
régions également en europe pour parler
d'elle des problèmes qui intéressent
l'europe l'énergie par exemple aux biens
le changement climatique pourquoi pas
je sais que d'une façon ou d'une autre
on peut le faire à new york pourquoi pas
vous riez est-ce que c'est pas possible
non c'est possible je voudrais remercier
vous remercier chers collègues vous
venez en russie depuis des années et
vous continuez à manifester l'intérêt
envers notre pays cela donne la
possibilité de parler à nos
collègues
votre humble serviteur
adopte ce format mais également nos
ministres le ministre des affaires
étrangères le maire de moscou également
cela nous donne la possibilité de parler
de notre vision
de la russie dans le monde actuel où est
ce que nos dirigeants
il y à l'impact positif
le
vice-ministre russe est de retour des
états unis il dit je suis surpris qu en
parlant avec les
faibles les numéro un de
l'administration américaine
du secrétariat à la défense
il y a un peu l'impression qu'ils n'ont
pas beaucoup d'informations sur la
russie et c'est pourquoi les forums
comme ceux ci sont très sollicités pour
parler en toute franchise
sentir
de quoi nous pensons et donne à
l'information en créant des décideurs
une matière pour prendre des décisions
je vous remercie beaucoup
[Applaudissements]